ten nine eight seven six five four three
[Applause]
[Music]
something
to the podcast
you guys make yourself heard here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
considering that we do this show in a
glass box with almost no feedback every
day this is going to be quite the
opposite we're going to have to weigh in
ourselves yeah way better it is way way
better if you want to join us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're also going to do
something a little different today we're
going to take questions from the live
studio audience here we've got
microphones and have some of the folks
have put in a pre-submitted questions
that they want to work into the show
today so either one of those will be
just fine and we're going to start off
with that so who's up first Kevin
Hey Kevin how are you how are you better
than I deserve where do you live
Indianapolis oh welcome to Nashville
thanks for coming in for this special
event how can we help you yeah so my
wife and I are on baby step seven kids
are through school houses paid no debts
about two years ago we maxed out our
401k and Roth and everything else as
full as we could then the market of
course went South and we decided to back
off to 15 on our 401 case we focused on
cash and putting a little money into our
house remodel
and the question is when do we get back
in what's a good sign
okay the wrong question
um the the right question is should I
have done that no you should not
um because there is all kinds of data
points all kinds of pieces of research
and you can go back through and study
the history of the stock market of
people who try to do what you're doing
which is called timing the market I'm
going to get out when it's high and in
what it's low would be the theory but
most people do quite the opposite of
that because they're emotionally driven
and they get out when it's low
and back in when it's high oh it's great
I'm getting in well it's exactly the
wrong time so the people if you compare
mathematically people that jump in and
out and try to catch those waves with
people who just get in and stay in
they are the ones that get in and stay
in outperform them about 40 percent it's
crazy how much the math changes so
that's why we always say no one gets
hurt on a roller coaster except those
that jump off in the middle so what I
would tell you is any time that you're
not in the market is a good time to get
in and then stay in and and so the other
thing is the market is down right now
and all but one time in the last 100
years when the market has been down the
year following is excellent and so if
you were going to violate all that stuff
I just said a minute ago and try to time
the market now's an excellent time to be
investing because it's on sale right now
you're at you're you're we used to when
I was a kid we'd go to Kmart anybody
remember Kmart come on and uh they put
these blue lights up
special you know and uh and it's on sale
and that's what the market is when it
goes down it's on sale and you want to
get in for sure yeah and the thing about
that is you know the Market's always
fluctuating but as long as you stay on
you're on the ride the moment you get
out and sell you're locking in that loss
and so you've just taken that you've
officially taken the hit once you get
out and so that's why I mean just stay
in it because it's going to adjust it's
normal and I think that's the thing that
folks need to get in their head these
adjustments it's normal it's cyclical
this is what we should expect we
shouldn't expect for it to just be
skyrocketing all the time it's
constantly changing and adjusting but we
know by looking at you know the history
and track record that although it's
going and fluctuating it's always
tracking upward even though it's
adjusting so that's really that gives me
peace at night and uh you know we're all
in here with you and we're keeping our
money in the market man amen thank you
Kevin good question John I had a yeah
I read a piece of research and I'm
curious your take on this as a as a PhD
in counseling that there's something
about the human brain that the the
financial people have found with surveys
that it takes three dollars of gain to
emotionally offset the damage that one
dollar of loss did yeah I I think it may
even be more than that now
um but it it takes we're so loss averse
that's just the way our bodies are
designed because they're over so many
thousands of years there was so much
scarcity so it's just designed for
hanging on to loss hanging on the loss
and man it takes a it takes some gain to
get back to that equilibrium and even
then your body puts a GPS pin and that
loss and it always wants you to remember
remember that time we lost remember that
time we lost remember the time we lost
and that works with money that works
with your marriage that works with your
kids that works with trauma all that
stuff is your body's trying to remind
you well and what ends up happening is
then we uh the little drama queen that
lives inside of us overstates this crap
my drama queen is incredible
so loud
I was going to actually ask Kevin like
here's what I know about me I get hyper
emotional about this stuff and so
literally once a quarter when the the
things are coming out my smart investor
Pro will call me and say you're gonna
get some mail
probably don't open it you're good
you're good and I'll say well what does
that mean he says you're good right but
this is I I've actually had to Outsource
comments put it on there like their
little Outlook a little Tickler call
John talking well they know I'm gonna
call them with a hundred questions that
I got off of YouTube like oh oh yeah
what if the dollar goes away and we're
trading rocks and what he needs is like
dude I'm just gonna call him
that that is what happens but then
people say things like well you know in
08 I lost everything in the stock market
I didn't no you did and if you did it's
because you exactly it's not possible
because you're still here unless you had
it in a single stock and that company
went broke but if you were in mutual
funds you did not lose everything it's
mathematically impossible it it actually
only went in half that's true she only
lost half and you didn't even lose half
unless you happen to bail out at exactly
the bottom which is a a unique ability
to get out at exactly the bottom
Dave that's one of my guests
so the trick is it's it
I think over the years of watching this
stuff personal finance is 80 Behavior
it's 20 head knowledge and over the
years of watching this stuff the way I
have learned to overcome the inner drama
queen is just an act of my intellectual
will I'm going to use my freaking brain
instead of the drama queen that says the
world's coming to an end
you know I've got to look at the actual
data points and say
jumping in and out bad staying in good
for a hundred freaking years you know
and we've always had incompetent
presidents we've always had a Congress
that was handcuffed to itself we've
always none of these things are new
here's what is I think new
is this idea that the news is here to
help us the news has one job and that's
to get your attention that's right it
gets your attention when it says you're
gonna die and so you you click on it the
news is not here to give you info it's
here to make you wild right it's not
your friend not your friend this is the
Ramsay show
folks I know you're doing more of what
you're doing for three whole hours
[Music]
you know how much it's going to be
before this one do I make a Mad Dash do
I stay do I wait should I stay or should
I go you wanna sing that a little bit
okay just checking uh anyway with that
being said for all of our friends that
are watching on YouTube my apologies for
not saying hi when I first came out hi
everybody say hi YouTube good to see you
guys love you guys make sure you add any
questions that you might have in the
comments section we'll be collecting
those as well we've already got some
that have come in from you guys uh one
of which being Dave do you think we'll
ever see an interview with Sharon
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and possibly on Rachel's show on
Rachel's show yeah
she and I you know she told me about 25
years ago I got her to do a speaking gig
and she got up and talked about marriage
and money in front of 800 people
and uh relatives were in the audience
and everything else and um and
she just hated she told me that she said
I'll stay married to you if you never
asked me to do that again
so yeah I I can't get her to do it it
would be the biggest thing we'd ever
done by far because she's like a woman
of mystery she's Austin Powers of wives
yeah what do you think the dream is like
could we bribe her enough like make it
in an exotic location and have puppies
everywhere and just like oh man if she
wants to go to an exotic location she
just books it
[Applause]
you know if you if you want to take this
on you can take it on buddy good luck
with that okay
that was an unintentional Flex you guys
did you see that it wasn't even it's
just like yeah it's just it's fine you
guys that's fine we're doing great
everything is fine all right we have
another question that came in through
the texting in is asked where or how was
the theme song chosen
uh not very intelligently when I
graduated from high school this is going
over YouTube right oh yes okay um the
night I graduated from high school me
and some other rednecks got in my car
and drove all the way to Daytona Beach
uh all night long do you remember what
car yeah 1974 Monte Carlo
was it in black and white no it was it
was a maroon with a white lindau top so
there you go and uh anyway the what was
the whole thing in black and white yeah
life was him yes that's what I was
asking you yeah and he's a little bit
slow on the update yeah we had
eight-track tapes and it would have been
journey and Boston and art and Jerry
Rafferty's uh Jerry Rafferty's Baker
Street and so that's the it's the
soundtrack of that moment in my life and
so I was looking for a cool Jazz Vibe
and I remember that that sax uh solo
that was in that thing that was incred
that is incredible and um thanks to the
Rafferty family for licensing it to us
and letting us use it all these years
it's pretty cool yeah it's cool anybody
think they could recreate that sax solo
really quick
[Applause]
for that I'll let you guys work on that
maybe next time I'm out somebody will
rise to the challenge with that being
said I'm gonna go ahead and pop off
we're gonna have about a 30 second
buffer if you need to just Shuffle in
your seat but don't go anywhere okay and
then we're gonna get started with our
next segment in about 25 seconds sound
good you guys are killing it I'll see
you guys in a bit
[Music]
we're back on the Ramsey Show and my
excitement to launch this with this live
studio audience and here at the Ramsey
live event center for the first time
ever I forgot to say I have two co-hosts
sorry about that Dr John deloney uh
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling offer
and
uh coast of the extremely popular
podcast with Dr Chandler talking about
mental health and relationships and
marriage stuff and kids stuff and it's
all mixed in there it's a wonderful
podcast always very interesting Jade
wash our newest Ramsay personality
is uh
for sure stealing the uh the popularity
contest around here without a doubt so
uh thanks get to hang out with both of
you guys today it's a good thing so
Ramsay show live from the stage of the
new Ramsey Event Center up next is
Catherine hi Catherine how are you
wait a minute there we go good hi
Catherine Hi how are you good where do
you live Cincinnati cool welcome to
Nashville how can we help today
so back in 2012 we came and did our
Consumer Debt free scream
and then getting to that point we
learned that we had the
um that our 80 20 loan was stupid and so
circumstances led us to lose our house
and then now we're 50 years old and in a
place where we could start thinking
about buying a house again but with
little save for retirement wondering if
we should just focus on retirement
no I I would get a house
um and uh the re I mean you don't have
to rush into it or panic but you know if
you want to retire with Comfort
um by the time you get to 70 65 and 70
you need a nest egg and a paid for house
here's why rents go up every year
period
the only way to control that is not be
renting
if you own a home the only costs that go
up are your insurance and taxes but your
payment even if you have still debt on
it does not go up assuming you do what
we say in a fixed rate 15-year mortgage
so your payment doesn't go up and and so
the largest line item in all of our
budgets or most people's budgets anyway
is their home their housing their
shelter and if that largest line item in
in your budget is going to go up
continually through retirement it'll
bust the bank
and so you don't want to start at age 65
renting through age 85 that's 20 years
of rent increases that's going to crack
and scramble in this day so we want to
get the house and then we want to get it
paid off as part of your 20 25 year plan
from today so yeah I would move towards
that again not in a panic but but just
to go well no been there done that I
don't like houses uh I got had a bad
experience no you need to do it again
this time just learn from what you did
before good down payment 15 year fixed
yeah and we know that homeowner
baby steps millionaire mathematical
equation we know that I think it's
something like 67 percent of
millionaires have paid four homes and so
we know that's a big part of it and
usually when we're looking at that that
that Shakedown it's two-thirds of it is
in the Investments and the other third
is in that Home Mortgage so I agree with
Dave wholeheartedly that that's the move
how much of this is are you just
freaked out to get back into this thing
tell me about that a lot
tell me about it losing your house is
emotional deeply traumatic yeah leaves
me not wanting another one yeah yeah I
had a bad car wreck I don't want to get
back in the car so on your body's doing
what it's supposed to be doing it's
trying to take care of you okay and its
job is not to
think about 30 years from now is to keep
you safe right this second and it's
going to remind you last time we did
this last time we did this last time we
did this so it's good to have a couple
of people in your corner that will walk
alongside you we'll go look at houses
with you that may sit down with you and
a realtor somebody that's going to be
able to put their hand on your wrist or
put their hand on your arm and say we're
good we're good this is right down just
you know keep it conservative and you
know what to do watch your budget you
know that whole thing and don't get
caught up in some kind of desperation
but as a Long play homeownership as you
said is one of the big components of
people that build wealth and because it
stabilizes your largest line item in
your budget good good question all right
let's go on to the phones and go to
Minneapolis Minnesota Tim is calling Hey
Tim welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
oh I'm just having a real real hard time
trying to get my
um Family fully on board with this whole
financial process
and I'm just looking for some advice on
how to get what what my girlfriend your
girlfriend
is that what you said
yeah run Tim run yeah just kidding well
well you know not just kidding John
stop just a second I gotta get a little
bit more detail here I apologize no go
ahead Tim you have a girlfriend and do
you have children with a girlfriend
yes how many
one how old
two years old two years old okay so when
you say trying to get my family involved
you meant trying to get my girlfriend
involved
yeah because you don't you don't yeah
two-year-olds don't get a vote we tell
them what to do
yeah but she also has two previous
children
but they don't get a vote
sure okay so you have a vote and uh if
your girlfriend's going to hang around
and you're gonna make babies then I
guess you're gonna have to talk about
marriage and doing this kind of stuff so
that we have a team that is moving
forward with a vision for our lives
yes yeah
how long has she been your girlfriend
about four years now okay
when is she going to be your wife
and I can afford it honey you made a
baby
you can afford it this weekend dude make
it happen
it's 26 okay anyway all of that to say
that comes into the equation of she
doesn't want to commit to sacrificing
for the future because you haven't
committed to her
there's a whole lot of relationship
stuff going on here am I missing
something doctor no no
Tim I'm not going to get on board with
your plans if you're not going to get on
board with me
that's what she's saying that just makes
that makes sense what what is it about
the last four years that you're you're
hesitant
because I've talked to 19 year olds who
have no dollars zero dollars and they're
like we're getting married and I'm like
whoa slow down and you this is four
years and you're like well I need to get
some more money why is that
well it's just a ring I just wanted oh
my God Tim you have a kid you got a kid
is that fair yeah besides that let me
help you with this I've been married 40
years the Rings don't last the little
dinky butt Ring We Got Married with is
in the safe and has been promptly and
properly replaced with a much larger
statement
I think that's a good point Tim why
don't you just get get what you can
afford put a ring on it and then you can
always upgrade later on down the line I
think I think you're using that as an
excuse to move forward the Ring The Ring
ain't got nothing to do with it you've
got something else that's blocking you
yep and here's what it looks like Tim it
looks like you sitting down with this
with your girlfriend and saying
I want to build a life with you we get
to decide we get to no matter what has
happened in the past we get to decide
what this future is going to look like
will you build this with me and when you
have that conversation then you're
talking about dreaming and you get very
specific and then that is where you
bring in this conversation about here's
where I feel safe here's here's how I
want to handle money here so I feel safe
handling money will you join me in this
that's a totally different conversation
then you need to do Dave Ramsey playing
like look if if I'm dating this guy and
I don't care if we have kids but he's
not asked me to marry him and he wants
me to do things with my money because
that's my money yeah we're having a
conversation you know what I'm saying
that's French
conversation
well that's exactly what's going on I
mean uh probably I mean exactly probably
but yeah but the uh uh that's not an
unusual thing that people face and Tim
I'll go ahead and give you one other
thing and tell you this there's again
back to research and data there's all
kinds of data that falls under the
bucket in the bucket of the marriage
Advantage
married couples old married couples that
have been living together for a long
time married have higher tendency to
build wealth they have better physical
health they have uh better relationships
uh but I mean it the shack up thing does
not have a good result financially long
term it doesn't end up so check that out
something to think about my brother
thank you for calling in we'll always
tell you the truth because we love you
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
show which is hard to say all in one
sentence but I have with me his his
producer Kelly Daniel here
[Applause]
she needs all the love and praise to
keep him on the rails okay thank you
guys it's just just pray pray for her
you want to see okay in the lobby you'll
be able to talk you hear that she asked
about my tattoos tattoos dude she's got
a thousand see all these inside jokes
that you two can be a part of if you
watch the Dr John alone show but I
wonder if Frank Kelly up here just to
ask you really quick what do you love
about this show my favorite thing about
the show is the way that John takes
these really complex mental health
questions and topics and breaks them
down in a way that everybody can
understand because once you understand
something it's a whole lot less scary
and then he gives everybody some sort of
actionable Step that they can take away
so as soon as they hang up the phone
they have something to do which makes
you feel more in control we get emails
all the time from people that have been
on the show a week or two weeks later
and said man I did that one or two thing
that you already told me to do and
things are so much better already and
that's just amazing to see something
flip so quickly I love that that's so
good so yeah we can clap on that
hey hold on Eddie can I just say this
real quick you can I won the lottery
when Kelly said she would
I'm a lot and when she said I'll I'll
take the reins of this thing thank you
so much
[Applause]
we got a treat for you guys we got a a
video to show you guys that shows you
just a little bit about what the Dr John
delone needs to shout check us out
so what's the show about oh man that's
hard brother what's up hey what are you
doing this is John with the Dr John
deloney show what's Happening we say the
show's about mental health and
relationships how to live a well life
listen take yourself out to dinner it is
rare that I hear a new one and that's a
new one so well done so the show can go
anywhere at any time on today's show we
talked to a woman who's in love with a
hypochondriac and it's so hard to a dad
who's trying to teach body positivity to
his young daughters dealing with Big T
trauma and family history to a sister
whose brother-in-law has screwed up
everything we talked to a young mom
whose husband keeps making sexual jokes
around the kids whoa stay tuned people
ask me all the time man how'd you learn
how to do this to take those calls and
get to it real fast and make some jokes
and bring the room up truth is I've been
doing that a long long time I got two
phds I've been doing this for a couple
of decades and I'm still learning every
day still trying to figure it out as I
walk alongside people
the guests are incredible they're
fantastic so it's fun to have guests man
who have done a bunch of fancy stuff I
love it they're hard in the show there's
collars just like you
yeah I mean my dad was angry growing up
he never
foreign
[Music]
arding your requests for how you can
best be loved yeah and that disregard is
violence
I don't want to try to take the kids
from her but I'm also feel like I'm
responsible for their safety as their
dad and all right so listen to me
carefully okay yeah your your instinct
is right and I heard you say at the end
there and I love your heart I don't want
to take
these kids from their mother
and what I would say to you is she is
screaming for somebody to please take
these kids for me before I hurt them
have you ever heard me lie to anybody
no
okay I'm not starting today it's not
your fault
you can't heal from hurt on your own and
that's what this show is for man and if
you will put in the work you'll give me
a call if you'll do the hard work you
will change your family tree and it
starts with you deciding you're worth
being well
[Music]
thank you
now there's some heavy stuff that comes
up in his shows but what we've been able
to see time and time again is that John
has been willing to walk with people in
their hardest moments and on the other
side of them sharing their deepest hurts
and struggles and insecurities we find
healing and hope and so that's why we're
highlighting all of these things is
because there are so many people that
are in need of Hope in so many areas of
life including their finances but also
in the relationships and in their mental
health so I invite you guys to check
that out to share with your friends to
tell everybody because am I right in
saying that this world is got more than
enough bad sources of bad information
and negativity yes
but let's do our part to fight against
that and Shine the Light in as many of
those dark places as we possibly can all
right we've got about a minute left as
you can see we've got some friends over
there they're going to be a part of our
next one
all right all right super excited
we're gonna be doing a debt free scream
live how many of you guys have seen a
debt-free screen before
all right how many how many of you guys
have done a debt free scream in this
you are in good company uh brace
yourself if you've never seen this or
experienced it before let yourself feel
all the feelings all right there it's a
good thing it's a good place to go there
John will be available in the lobby if
you want to talk about them afterwards
it's totally fine
but in addition to that I'm gonna go
ahead and get off the stage we got an
incredible segment for you guys coming
up right now in about 22 seconds you
guys are killing it I'll be back in just
a bit I'll see you then
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show live
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality are my
co-hosts today we are live with a live
studio audience right here
I mean the Ramsay Event Center
a lot of fun today as we launched this
open this building and start to use it
for what it was designed for which is to
serve you folks whether you're watching
from somewhere else we're serving you
that way or whether you're here in the
room we're serving you Dustin and Erica
are on the stage joining us to do a debt
free stream welcome guys thank you
[Applause]
where do you guys live Richmond Virginia
very cool welcome to Nashville all right
how much debt did you pay off we have
paid off 289 737.65
and how long did this take you 86 months
okay and your range of income during
that did you start this when you were
11. it feels like it 95
000 and we finished at 300 000. wow wow
okay moving on up the story here what
are you guys what do you do for a living
now
um I'm a registered nurse and I run my
own business I do architectural Drafting
and design and I have to say this
building is absolutely beautiful all
right thank you wow Dave Druid himself
on the back of a napkin not really yeah
no it's a great it's a great
architectural firm that we've worked
with for the whole campus so uh Gresham
and Smith have been good to us thank you
thank you very very much well so this is
quite a journey 86 months I mean you all
yours income has gone through the roof
you've gone crazy what kind of debt was
the uh 290 000. uh the debt was four
thousand dollars was a family loan
about 16 000 was credit cards over
twenty seven thousand car loans
uh forty eight thousand in student loans
8 500 in medical debt
and eighty six thousand two hundred
forty dollars in restitution when I was
17 which I'm very ashamed to even have
to admit and then 100 000 for a Parent
PLUS Loan oh wow man you guys were
normal and then some yes man so how long
have y'all been married
um we got married in uh May 2015 2014.
yeah
it's been it's been a long time you can
mess that up he can't okay just be quiet
dude take a dive that's okay honey and
uh yeah so about the time you got
married you started on this whole thing
you said we're gonna do this Ramsay
thing it was a year later we bought a
house you bought a house and then you
realize we can't eat
well we found out we got pregnant as
soon as we bought the house and then we
realized we couldn't afford the kids so
we can't afford the kid can't afford the
house can't afford it can't afford food
we had to live near family so we didn't
have family to watch our kids so daycare
was an expense we had to consider
absolutely okay so that basically the
budget just caved in on you and that was
your wake-up call yeah okay so tell us
what happened then
so Dustin went looking so we decided
um when we first set out to see what
daycare cost
um what can we do and he found you and
then yeah it was a lot to get me on
board I was like heck no
um yeah because this is working so well
I know
[Laughter]
um so then we sat down and we figured
out if we can pay off my parents who
helped us with the down payment on the
house if we can pay off our credit cards
we'll be able to afford daycare so that
was the goal so we got that done I think
maybe a week before we had Declan so
that was the start and then it's been a
long journey since okay but that got you
moving yeah but so you didn't just go
there and then quit you kept going yeah
yeah
um after that we continued with
everything and we had finished paying
what I went to school so I started
working I was in retail I went to school
for music Just Like You Jade hence the
hundred thousand dollars of student loan
debt that got me nothing
um so then yeah
so I ended up working in management in
retail hated my my life he worked and
got a job and then um
started his own business and that was
able to afford me to quit retail and
start school so we went back to school
when Declan was a year and a half so
that was about three years of just one
income during this time and then once I
started working we were able to pick it
up and then covet hit so I could pick up
all those hours which helped us to get
to that end goal so covet was was
considerably scary if you were a nurse
but you could also make boatloads of
money yeah five 12 hour shifts is a lot
with two little ones yeah yeah yeah and
and it's scary the whole time too that's
yeah but they're writing you large
checks so yes they are almost battle
almost battle checks yes so you found
the show as a result of trying to figure
out child care right you go you're
Googling something and you find it did
you guys ever get connected to like
Financial Peace University or what was
that on round we did we started that uh
early on and then we attended that
together before we had kids I think she
was was pregnant no we had Declan and we
had already paid off about 40 000 and
then we went and did Financial Peace it
was just we felt like it needed to
happen so we could put all the pieces
together I didn't need to hear anything
else Dave got Dave spoke my language and
he got me right away but but you know
the problem with just catching stuff on
YouTube and there's nothing against that
but you don't get the whole system what
you said you don't see the holistic way
how this is all going to weave together
in the end you can just kind of go
you're just picking out the little
pieces and if you don't see how they all
fit together it's harder so Erica what
was it that turned you and got you going
because you said I'm like no okay
um we finished in 20
2021 and we paid off like 130. he went
to ITT Tech I'll let him finish that
down if anyone knows and John has spoken
about that as well so my student loans
was in limbo I paid on student loans
during Cove but then I stopped because I
was in a lawsuit it was not part of the
mass forgiveness because my school shut
down
um and so we were in limbo for a little
bit so we were just piling up money
waiting on to the decision in the
lawsuit and once it came out that it was
forgiven I paid on my restitution which
I owed 80 000 left this was from when I
was 17 running around with the wrong
kids
um and the reason why it was so much
because I was with two other people and
the one committed suicide so instead of
it being split three ways it was split
two so I had to pay for not only my
mistake but someone else's mistake so I
had a lot of resentment and feelings
towards that and I almost thought like I
wanted to die with it
but once we got to the point where she
was on board the payoff her Parent PLUS
Loan it was all yeah debt free to you
really means free yeah yeah hey to
people people who have debts that like
may not have been theirs or they didn't
realize what they were signing up for
whatever
just watching you say that there is
something about your body posture that
changes when you say
I shouldn't have but I'm just gonna go
do it because it's the right thing to do
I'm gonna go knock it out and be done
with it and you walk six six inches
taller I feel like I'm 10 feet tall and
it happened right when your book came
out on your past change your future and
that's exactly what I did it just
dissolves shame sometimes action just
saying I'm I'm taking it it just
dissolves shame I was very ashamed of it
and I didn't want to I don't tell people
this this is the only time in my adult
life I'm really telling people out in
the open yeah but I feel like I just
can't let it be a secret because you
talk about secrets and stuff I feel like
I I conquered that it's incredible it's
awesome all right let's bring the kiddos
up I want to introduce you yeah bring
the kiddos on up
so you brought you brought your babies
with you what are their names and ages
so this is Declan he's seven and then
Ayla she just turned three all right
very cool well you guys changed your
family tree we're proud of you well done
Dustin Erica Declan and Layla
Ayla Ayla Ayla yeah 200 or I'm sorry I'm
gonna do it again 290 000 paid off in 86
months making 95 to 300 and a lot of
transformation during that time
wonderful story count it down let's hear
a debt free scream team three two one
[Applause]
oh man
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
how cool was that
oh my gosh
all right this bridge is about two
minutes we got about two minutes two and
a half-ish minutes until we're gonna go
back into our next segment you guys this
cool thing about this is you get a
visual picture of not just a couple's
Journey changing but how that's changing
their family tree and it's just
beautiful uh we we get to see this all
the time and I'm glad that you guys got
to be a part of this today but I still
don't get tired of it like I still make
sure to go down and be a part of these
moments because they mean so so very
much and you guys did such an incredible
job this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity hopefully once in a lifetime
opportunity okay don't be going back to
that once in a lifetime opportunity and
you guys got to cheer alongside of them
so so so great all right a couple of
things to go over before we uh head into
our next section first of all can I just
take a moment with you guys in this room
can we just say thanks to our production
and volunteer crew that has made all of
this happen
especially my guy Jake over here he's
been hustling so hard he's essentially
just slept here for the last two months
because he's had so much to do and he's
just been killing it so thank you guys
thank you so much everyone in the blue
shirt make sure you smile at them and
tell them thanks a lot of them are team
members that have worked all week and
still volunteered to be here just to be
a part of this weekend so thank you guys
appreciate you so so very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
back live from the Ramsey Event Center
with a whole live studio audience it's a
lot of fun
Jade Washington Ramsey personality and
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality are
my co-host today if you uh didn't know
I've got a note here somewhere I'm
supposed to make sure I hit this that we
are going to be live streaming the first
two lessons of in uh the smart
conference in the morning with Rachel
Cruz and George Campbell and if you
haven't signed up it is a free live
stream you can't come because it's sold
out so uh you but you can watch the live
stream and wherever you are in America
and we're gonna make that available
completely free did I mention it's free
go to ramseysolutions.com live and join
us for smart conference in the morning
Saturday morning for smart conference
good stuff all right Jay is up next hi
Jay how are you great good afternoon
nice to meet you guys and thank you for
the opportunity to ask the question
get right to it maybe step seven blessed
to be on measure been able to live and
save more than ever I ever even imagined
possible in the giving phase of that
could you guys help with some how you
prioritize where you give and what are
the right things so that you don't feel
pressure or shamed with everything going
on in the world yeah
um you know sometimes when I get uh uh
too busy because I feel this this
pressure to help as many people as we
can and then I get fatigued uh Sharon
will get I'll get home and she'll go uh
hey you're not Jesus the job's taken
and we've kind of taken that uh and
applied it to our giving
you know we can't fix the world Ramsey
Family Foundation doesn't have infinite
resources as a matter of fact I would
guess that of the people that come to us
for the different Ministries and so
forth that come to us we say no to 95 of
them
um and so and they're all just about
every one of them are valid they're
really they're legitimate needs I mean
there's a child at the end of this that
needs some help and I can't help them
I've only got we've only got so much
money and we put that money on this
thing and that means we can't put it on
this thing and
um and so you got to get comfortable
with the idea you're not Jesus you're
not God
um you cannot do everything that needs
to be done every you can't there's no no
person on the planet has enough money to
to cover all the needs of the planet
it's just not there and it's not how it
works and so there's no end to that
until you until you divorce yourself
from this need to serve everything so I
I I I don't feel guilty when we don't
give to those I feel sad sometimes I
wish we could I wish we had more funding
that we could do that but but we don't
and so it's not a guilt it's more of a
just that's that's a really good one
let's try to get to that maybe next year
or you know let's let's just keep that
in the back of our mind see if there's a
certainly pray for them we can do that
you know but I can't be everywhere I
can't do everything and I can't give
enough to cover all the needs and if if
me taking care of everybody is
um what it takes to get rid of my guilt
I'm always going to have guilt so you
just got to reframe it in that sense
John any ideas I I the two things that
my wife and I do one is we sit down and
we what are things that we want to see
different in the world and we keep those
things really close right I love the
right hand and left hand like I it's
just a personal thing between me and my
wife like we're really troubled by this
or we want to help this particular
family out and and
that's that's between us and Them the
second thing is it's it's turned into I
don't play video games I'm just not that
cool it's turned into that type of
enjoyment for me going to Waffle House I
take my son to Waffle House every
Tuesday morning he's a middle schooler
and watching him the first time we
tipped a waitress a hundred dollars on a
20 meal
and watching her start crying and lean
up against the coffee machine because
this is going to keep her lights on and
him going oh man right it's that's that
to me so
um I I give I know it's helping other
people but honestly at this point it's
I'm benefiting I think probably more I
love it so it's just become a a fun
thing to do
you want anything I think you guys
covered it I have a similar story as
John did and I just think that learning
to enjoy those moments and you know my
screen says how do we live and give
without feeling ashamed and I think that
you know the Earth is God's and
everything in it and if he's blessed you
with these gifts and and you have the
wherewithon to understand that you're
stewarding that and you're being
generous and you're doing all the things
and you're doing you're being led as you
see fit then you know you're doing right
man you're doing the right thing thank
you sir we appreciate you
[Applause]
up next is John hi John how are you I'm
good good where do you live Findlay
Illinois good welcome to Nashville
thanks how can we help I was wondering
how to convince friends and Etc that you
can live without credit or credit cards
besides just example
um
uh
well I haven't been able to
um all my friends use them yeah
I've got friends and family members uh
the vast majority of them don't do a
stinking thing I teach so um uh you know
and uh so being an example in front of
them I I
um
early early in this process I I the
first thing I ever did with this
material this biblical ways of handling
money was I was teaching a Sunday school
class at my church and I was so zealous
and so passionate I wanted everyone to
do this stuff because it set you free
and you can become prosperous and you
can become generous and that the
benefits are just unbelievable and I was
I was just so passionate about it like I
had discovered the key and and uh and it
was really disturbing to me that not
everybody was and uh so I spent a lot of
energy trying to convince somebody that
didn't give a crap so um somewhere in
there I decided I'd no longer answer
questions unless they're asked yes
and people ask me three hours a day on
here questions I answer them but if my
friend drives up in front of the house
which happened not long ago in his new
car that was leased
um he didn't come over there for a
lecture he didn't come over there for me
to tell him he's stupid although he is
um but he didn't come over there for
that he came over there showed me his
new car now if you ask Dave what do you
think oh he'll tell you now there's a
problem then because you've done stepped
in it
yeah that's the truth I mean but if you
I mean and if that's my rule that's my
that's my life rule too I'm not gonna
answer questions where I almost force
you to ask I'll do that too but uh but
you have to ask meaning that there's
some tendon some indication that you
will actually do what the answer is but
people who are running around this
culture all over the place answering
questions that nobody asked uh they're a
pain in the butt and so
um I just I just quit doing it I just I
love people where they are and if they
need me they know what I am they know
who I am they they know you they know
you live debt free they know how you are
and so and they know if they need to if
they hit the wall and there's a problem
and they go man I can't I can go to John
because he can tell me how to do this
now that I've really screwed up enough
that God got my attention you know but
uh but until then you know you can just
all the sermons in the world won't work
let me try because you can't fabricate
that moment everybody hits that moment
in different ways when they realize man
I've got a change or you know you've
you've got that I've had it moment or
that that moment where it just hits the
fan and it's like I've got to do
something different and until that
person is at that moment willing to make
a change looking for something different
then you're just I mean you're you're
hitting a brick wall you're running into
it every time because they you can't
create that for someone they've got to
do that themselves and hit that moment
themselves both of these questions to me
are about identity like I'm so some I I
have value because I can give a lot of
money away or I have value because I've
got a lot of knowledge away and I want
to tell everybody you got value whether
you got something to give away or not
you got value just because you are and
if your identity is I only have worth
because I need to give you this I need
to give you this and give you this
that's not a problem with the receiver
that's a problem with us and I'm looking
at me because I'm a pathological Giver
like I got I got to tell you how smart I
am and the world's like no you're we're
good we're good so there's something
about me having to look in the mirror
and be okay with me and that's hard be
okay with my relationship to God be okay
with my relationship with my wife and my
kids that's really really hard because
culture says yell give give and I I just
got to unplug from that being my
identity yeah John thank you good
question Jade warshaw Dr John deloney
this hour here on the Ramsey show live
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney
special for you like I said we're going
to be highlighting shows all throughout
this time together and so I have with me
show producer Alex chadfield who's here
he works on the Ken Coleman show
Kent's going to be joining us on stage
in a little bit but first we wanted to
give you guys a highlight of what he
does on the Ken Coleman show and Alex I
know we're going to show a clip in just
a second but maybe you could tell us a
little bit about it and like what we're
gonna see in this
so uh the average person uh uh is
dissatisfied with the work study shows
that only 21 of people feel uh
satisfaction enjoyment with their work
yeah so uh this is an example of a clip
of a caller who called into the show
actually and um and just what so many
people feel every single day absolutely
okay so without further Ado here's a
clip from the Ken Coleman show
[Applause]
I can hi Eileen
Hi how are you today well I'm living the
dream what are you doing
uh just being miserable well you have
come to the right place because we're
going to get you out of that misery
right let's get you out of it
oh good thank you appreciate it what's
going on
um I've been a environmental health and
safety manager for 13 years and
currently I work at Amazon wow and my
experience has been extremely toxic
bless your heart you're about ready to
break down
I already have what's going on
um what's causing this emotion
I don't want to go back to work oh sweet
Eileen I'm so sorry
so I just need a plan yes to land my new
dream job okay well let's first talk
about
um
this powerful emotion
you're just gutting it out every day
when you go in
yes
um what do you make
at Amazon
um I think about 145 a year okay so
that's our challenge because we need
that 145 or something really close to it
yes or no yes okay so are you applying
are you looking aggressively right now
um I've been aggressively applying for
the last four months I've had multiple
interviews I've had people where they're
like like rivian like oh my gosh you
gotta work here I go through the process
between three to nine interviews and
then I don't get picked that's okay you
gotta keep going you you have no choice
we we just keep going what I want you to
do is I'm going to give you my book The
Proximity principle because I think this
is the Deep dive read for you this is
all about Connections you got to keep
going but we've got to start really
leveraging relationships that you have
people who know somebody who know
somebody who knows somebody I don't care
if it's eight levels
that's how you're going to get the job
oh okay we got we don't want to just
apply and go through the normal process
we want to Target a company here a
company there a company there and we go
who do I know that works over there who
do I know that knows somebody that works
over there and we're working that
connection
hey making their way back out to the
shower the show
you guys know Dave he's an old friend
introduce you to Ken Coleman
America's sweetheart George Campbell
over there on my left
ah apparently you're the room sweetheart
as well they like wow she's so kind fan
favorite that's really great all right
so uh make sure that you guys tune in
and catch the Ken Coleman show it is
fantastic he walks people through all of
these different walks of life wherever
they're at meeting them and we call them
we lovingly call them America's career
coach but I want to focus on that word
coach because that's exactly what he
does is he meets you where you are and
helps you get to where you want to be
all right so make sure you tune in
because I know a lot of you were like oh
man I'm really feeling for that lady and
a lot of you were like shoot is Amazon
hiring because 145 sounds pretty great
right now make sure you can hear
something out of them oh he's got so
many resources he's got so much wisdom
we just got a quick flyover In that clip
but he's got all of these ways for us to
be able to find exactly what we're meant
to do in this world how to do it with
passion purpose and Clarity I highly
highly recommend you guys check that out
as the boys are getting set up here
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Studios it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're here in the Ramsey
live event center for the first time
ever with a few friends hang out hanging
out with some good people welcome guys
[Applause]
somewhere around 1500 folks here in the
live studio audience George Campbell
Ramsey personality host of the newly
minted George camel YouTube channel and
co-host of smart money happy hour is my
co-host
also co-hosting this hour Ken Coleman of
the Ken Coleman show helping people with
their work with their careers and with
the number one best-selling book
paycheck to purpose
we'll be taking calls from all across
America at triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're also going
to take some questions here from our
live studio audience and get to hang out
with you guys in person in this process
so let's start with the studio audience
up first is Tommy hi Tommy how are you
hey doing great how are you better than
I deserve sir where do you live uh
Georgia wow good welcome to Nashville
and uh your question for the day my
question is so my fiance and I are 24
years old recently engaged three weeks
ago and uh congratulations yeah thank
you pretty much
my question for you all is if you could
go back and talk to your 24 year old
self what are the top three pieces of
advice that you would give yourself
wow should we narrow it down there's
three of us that's nine pieces of advice
I feel you putting the pressure I'll go
fast and leave all the time so I think
the first thing is I would tell myself
to learn how to fail faster and what I
mean by that is step into things try
things faster fail get into failure
quickly because the quicker I fail the
quicker I learn and then I would also
learn how to get over the failure faster
so that's what I mean by fail fast jump
into stuff now not be crazy risky but
just try things do things that you want
to do and learn through the failure and
then get over the failure second thing
would be hang out with older people more
you know I'm middle aged now and I don't
feel that way except for after a round
of golf but uh I I think that
the people that have reached the 60s and
70s and 80s have so much to teach us
even now at my age and
yeah and I
I wish I had sat with some older people
in my dad's church more and and asked
them about life and asked them about
marriage and parenting so that would say
that and then I'd say you said 24 so
Stacy and I are getting ready to
celebrate 25 years of marriage in May
and so we I got married at 23
. thank you very much and I would have
said uh apologize faster
and better yeah because you're wrong
yeah she's not you're wrong
yeah so he's absolutely right so that'd
be my three things
for me I'm gonna I'm gonna start with
this one for the engaged couple the best
marriage advice I think is to outserve
each other and if you do that from 24 to
74 you will have an amazing 50-year
marriage uh on the money side and on the
life side you have time I meet so many
people who are 22 or 32 and they're
going that I ruined my life I made money
mistakes there's no time dude you have
so much time and the third one is don't
squander it and so be intentional and
realize that patience is is the game and
think long term have long-term Vision
long-term goals and you'll have a great
life and a great marriage wow you guys
are good
y'all y'all ought to do this for a
living that's pretty impressive I'm not
sure I've got anything as good as theirs
um you know I I think one of the things
that Sharon and I learned through going
broke and 40 years of marriage is just
to we spend an awful lot of time being
uh talking through things and reaching
agreement before we move forward
so we don't do giving substantial giving
we don't do purchases uh we don't uh we
run our calendar and our budget together
and so we she says time to do calendars
and we sit down and look at okay I'm
gonna be traveling here I'm gonna be in
Salt Lake City this month I'm going to
be in Anaheim I'm going to be doing this
and you know we've got this weekend
smart conference I've got May I've got
entree leadership so I know what my work
stuff is and uh and we've got this with
the kids and we've got this with the
grandkids my grandkids
softball and t-ball and soccer are on my
calendar uh don't make all of them but I
make some of them and they're at least
there where I can see them so managing
our time managing our money and being in
agreement on where they're going is how
we have managed our lives together and
it's caused us to be in agreement Jesus
says your treasure is where your heart
is and when you can agree on your
spending you've really agreed on your
fears your future your uh uh your dreams
you're agreeing on those things and when
you're not in agreement you spend so
much time and angst pulling at each
other and pulling away or do that
um the second thing I would tell you to
do is both of you make sure you get a
really tight friend group of people that
win
I've been very careful to put a group of
guys in my life group of men in my life
for 25 years now there was a group for
the first 14 years was a Bible study
every Wednesday morning at my office and
then after that it's been a different
group of guys or some overlap but for
the for the next 10 years and currently
today 10 of my closest friends and six
of those will carry my casket if I go
before them these are my men and they've
got strong marriages strong spiritual
wealth they're smart at business they're
well read many of them have written more
best sellers than I have they're
successful in their area and you become
who you hang around with
so be really careful who you hang around
with I mean you can love anybody and I'm
not saying snob people or something like
that but I'm talking about your crew the
people that you spend time with because
you're going to use the same language
they use you're going to use this you're
going to read the same books they read
you're going to adopt the same values
they do you're even going to have their
accent it's ridiculous and so choose it
carefully choose it carefully be not
deceived evil company corrupts good
habits the Bible says and that is very
true so not nearly as good as those guys
but that's my two no that's good I
and I would tell you Dave said something
that made me think of something and
Stacy and I have
we've just learned recently
walking through this but the people you
start out with
won't necessarily be the people you
finish with her it breaks your heart and
it's hard I gotta tell you and so be
okay with that so I would tell myself be
okay with that because we are we are
going this way this is the life that
we're going to choose to live and not
everybody's going to be on that same
Lane if we look at the life as a track
Lane and we're in Lane six there should
be some people that you'll start with
that won't finish with you and that's
going to hurt but you're going to have
to choose to live your life and you
don't you don't control them no you do
not it's not like you climb the ladder
and kick people yeah you didn't say
leave us yeah that's not what's going on
that's right it's not you're kicking
people off the ladder they chose to jump
that's right or chose to not climb yep
or chose to
misbehave in some other way invalidating
their presence in your life they just do
that you can't keep them from it's just
uh it hurts hurts good question sir
congratulations very well done this is
the Ramsey shower
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show is
my co-host Today George Campbell Ramsay
personality is my other co-host this
hour rather we're taking calls from the
auditorium here our questions from the
auditorium floor as well as calls from
across America at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chris is next up
hey Chris how are you great how are you
better than I deserve what's up
um so as you're aware The Total Money
Makeover was published in 2003
and I'm sure you're also aware that the
first baby step is to save a thousand
dollar starter emergency fund so my
question since the book has been
released for 20 years and with the
current dramatic Horizon inflation do
you still feel a thousand dollars is the
correct amount to start to be successful
with your plan
a thousand dollars was not enough in two
thousand three
[Applause]
was never designed to be enough it's
enough to buy an alternator for a car or
a tire maybe one or two uh it's enough
to uh take your kid to the pediatrician
if they're sick but it's not enough to
be a real emergency fund it's enough to
keep the little things from kicking your
butt off the get out of debt wagon
because what we when we first started
this stuff years ago I just I I said use
all your savings have zero
and that didn't work honestly that and
if you had come to Financial Peace
University when I was teaching it with
an overhead projector before we had the
baby steps I just was Hardcore just you
know I'm like you're in boot camp shut
up sell everything use all your money
don't whine get your butt out of debt
because if you don't get out of debt
none of this is going to work and but we
discovered pretty quickly that every
little thing that came along that wasn't
in their little budget the first few
months knock them out knock them out
knock them out and then they would give
up hope the people in financial piece
would give up hope because they couldn't
do the system the system wasn't working
so we decided okay we're gonna give you
just a little bit of of a beginner
starter emergency fund just to knock the
little stuff off uh if you have a car
transmission go out it's not enough if
you have something big happen it's not
enough it's not designed to be enough
it's just there and and to cover while
you'd go through the typically it's
about 18 months out of the 10 million
people have been through Financial Peace
University it's 18 months to get out of
debt not counting your house baby step
two now that means some of them do it in
three months and some of them do it in
30 but the average is 18. so it's
designed just to keep the little crap
away but if if your car blows up during
that 18 months it's not enough and it
never was designed to be enough so it
doesn't need to be a inflation adjusted
because it wasn't supposed to be enough
but good question thank you sir
I just want to say something very quick
about inflation because that's all we
hear about it makes you click and that's
what the media is supposed to do but
understand that the reason why inflation
is stubborn folks is now wage pressures
and that's fancy economic language that
I barely understand but it means that
hourly rates and salaries at our
all-time high and the reason why your
Burger King combo or your bread costs
more is because they're paying the
person in those positions at Burger King
and the grocery store more so when I
hear that question I think it's a good
question but let's also understand that
we the people still have tremendous
individual responsibility and power to
see in this economy where we have about
four and a half million more jobs
available than there are people who are
unemployed and right now in the gig
economy which means I go out and do
something part-time and freelance
economy there is more opportunity to
make really good money so if you're
gazelle intense and at a thousand
dollars isn't enough you go make use of
more money and pay for that alternator
you can go make plenty of money in this
economy right now that's a great Point
Ken
and on top of that Ken makes a great
Point people don't think about okay
let's walk through that worst case
scenario you have an emergency that's
more than a thousand dollars what do you
do we tell you to pause the baby steps
and stack up cash really quickly and
most people do in the plan they didn't
have much more than a thousand to begin
with and so this hypothetical scenario
where they had so much money could cover
all these emergencies it just doesn't
exist if we made the emergency fund and
baby step one five thousand dollars we
would have a tiny portion of the
population be able to do that and have
the hope and motivation to continue but
Chris's question if you were going to
say the plan is let's say we got to baby
step three and instead of saying three
to six months of expenses we said ten
thousand dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars in 2003 now today would we need
to say okay that's not correct anymore
we would need to adjust it because it's
not enough if it if it was enough in
2003 to have a fifteen thousand dollar
baby step three it's not enough in 2023.
so his his concept is valid but it
doesn't apply to baby step one and the
good news is is that the other baby
steps are not fixed amounts that's the
only one that's a fixed amount the rest
of them are percentages
and so they flow out of that percentage
and the percentages will adjust with
inflation and with wage pressures and
with everything else so you know okay a
million dollars isn't what it used to be
in your retirement account true
but we million dollars is just a
milestone it wasn't the only target we
said put 15 away and maybe step four and
hopefully 10 million is what you get you
know I mean uh so you know it's adjusted
that way uh and so three to six months
of expenses your expenses have changed
since 2003 they should have yeah and so
your emergency fund would need to be
bigger today your baby step three one so
his concept is accurate in questioning a
number a fixed number from 2003 but it
also gives me the opportunity to explain
that baby step one wasn't ever designed
to be that in the first place because I
get the you know some of these idiots on
Tic Tac or whatever that are
um you know Dave Ramsey doesn't know
what he's talking about his stuff's
outdated yeah that's right it's how you
know the law of gravity is now outdated
so
but Dave you've you've told people on
air before you've have you tweaked that
thousand dollar number based on a very
specific situation
where you went all right fine you can do
1500 you could do 500. you know what are
the scenarios the other thing I realized
is that uh uh uh this didn't you know
none of these baby steps came from the
Bible they came from our experiences
of coaching thousands of people and uh
so they're not absolute truth in that
sense uh they're they're based on
Concepts that are absolute truth but
they're not the baby steps themselves
are not magical all they are is a clear
path and everybody needs a clear path to
do whatever they're going to do Ken
teaches a clear path to get into a new
position in a step-by-step process
you've got to have a clear path you know
if you get ready to go to college and
you want to graduate there's a clear
path it's called a syllabus take the
freaking classes get the degree you know
there's a clear path you know what you
have to do to get there and so winning
always involves a clear path and a
process so that part and I'm aware
George that somebody's going to decide
to do whatever they want to do because
they're like grown-ups and stuff but uh
but I'm not going to vary on the air
because every time we vary on the air we
we not only vary for that single person
that's on this that we're talking to but
22 million other people are listening
and so then you start to blow up the
whole idea and the beauty of the baby
steps of the clear path including the
one that Ken uses is uh we don't vary
from it because it it and then people
start to believe it because it's a
proven path it's a proven system and if
you submit yourself to a proven system
then you can you can hit those goals so
it's a good it's a really good
discussion everyone thinks they're
special everyone thinks they're unique
they're the outlier you know like well
Dave you don't understand my situation
you are but that doesn't exclude you
from the law of gravity yeah yeah that's
right yeah that's special you're going
to hit the sidewalk shut up I mean it's
like you know that's it I mean you're
not you're special but you're not you
know that we all are I mean you're
unique you have unique situations and
that's what makes the show interesting
people calling in with unique uh family
life and unique situations you're going
that's cray-cray you know it's
entertaining you know and but the
principles that we guide Our Lives by
um you know like you all told the young
guy there you know be sure you apologize
early and often that's a great principle
okay does it apply every single time no
I don't need to apologize to my wife if
she runs over me with a car you know
it's her fault you know that's a very
specific scenario I don't know but I'm
just trying to think of something
bizarre right you know somebody
misbehaving you know so but but but is
apologizing a good principle you bet it
is quickly early and often you bet it is
it's a wonderful it's a sign of a
strength of confidence of humility it's
a you know it's weak people they can't
apologize it requires courage so it's
you know those are those are simple
things but these simple Concepts do
apply universally this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
smiling wave everyone smiling wave
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there you are you know how many
photos Dave's taken of me in his
lifetime zero
wow
I shouldn't have asked for that he faked
it I know you saw it he just gets them
off the internet they're more exciting
that way hey guys I'm back out here with
show producer Alex Chatfield
yeah that's what I'm talking about
you know it's pretty sweet having uh our
hosts cycle through it's kind of like we
get to binge watch the show you don't
even have to like click next episode
it's just Auto playing but in case you
are not getting enough we have a brand
new show to introduce you guys to the
George camel YouTube show extravaganza
it's about time we've all been waiting
waiting the people have spoke in there
that's why we're just gonna use that
picture we'll take a picture of that
picture George that is a striking photo
thank you that's great Photoshop does
wonders Photoshop does do I think we're
gonna show you guys in his hair looks
like he's got highlights look like a
Backstreet Boy tell you what what people
don't know is because George is so
Thrifty he got that jacket on sale at
Gap Kids
the kids clothing's cheaper
and that's exactly the kind of content
you're going to get on the George
Campbell YouTube channel we're going to
show you guys the clip from this but I
wanted Alex to kind of give you a little
bit of context about this clip and then
tell the people why they need to watch
the show
uh well first of all we need to watch
the show because if you follow the
trends you'll fall for the traps that's
something that George says all the time
so if you want to avoid those mistakes
uh you want to definitely subscribe to
this channel also we're going to share a
clip from a video that released
Wednesday called uh how crypto
millionaires lost their fortune and so
in 2022 we saw a huge crash in crypto so
George unpacks that he also talks about
where you should put your money instead
of crypto so great great stuff and you
can experience George's wit and humor
along with that yeah we love it all
right let's check this out this is from
George's brand new YouTube channel that
just launched this week check it out
can we all just hearken back to better
times simpler times to when crypto was
going to make us all rich and you were
actually kind of weird if you weren't in
on it you didn't own any and in the
aftermath of covid nfts and crypto coins
like Bitcoin and ethereum shot up in
value Bitcoin even hit an all-time high
in November of 2021 at almost 68
thousand dollars but then crypto Market
crashed and it crashed hard
[Music]
which made commercials like this
age-like milk
fortune favors the brave
fortune favors those who didn't listen
to Matt Damon as it turns out you should
really stick to acting instead of
investing advice he had a heck of a run
there Goodwill Hunting the porn series
the oceans movies 4 vs Ferrari the
Martian Interstellar The Departed did
you really need the check from
crypto.com I just couldn't help myself I
know I'm a trickster many experts
sounded the alarm early on about how
volatile and unpredictable
cryptocurrencies can be and others also
said the crypto Market was in a bubble
and here's the thing about bubbles they
eventually pop and when the crypto
bubble popped the bubble blowers
disappeared real quick so here's how it
all went down in May of 2022 two
cryptocurrencies Luna and Tara USD
suddenly collapsed by July of 2022
Bitcoin had lost roughly 70 percent of
its value since reaching that all-time
high it was hovering around 21 000 per
coin and the other big digital
cryptocurrencies like ethereum and
Dogecoin well they took some significant
hits too and that's not even mentioning
that basically all FTX Investments are
now worth zero dollars and it's gone so
why is crypto crashing well for one
confidence in crypto as a legitimate
investment is now starting to fade since
the beginning of the year trusting
crypto has plummeted by 18 and more than
a third of crypto owners reported
selling some of their Bitcoin in July
and one study shows that only about
eight percent of Americans feel
positively about crypto which
coincidentally is the same percentage of
Americans who feel positively about the
bachelor franchise you literally just
came in here to act like that are you
kidding me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
very good I'm just saying
Fonzie jump in the shark
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show we're live in the Ramsey
Event Center with 1500 of our closest
friends
George Campbell Ramsey personality uh
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host we uh uh what you may not know
about the Ramsey personalities we
actually enjoy hanging out uh together
all the time anyway and so we get up
here and cut up uh it's kind of like
what it is when we're sitting in a
meeting somewhere we just cut up and
carry and argue and fuss and fight and
make fun of each other and everything
else so it's kind of part of the gig and
uh we just enjoy hanging out with each
other because
um I like hanging out with smart people
it's a good thing hey by the way uh
speaking of smart people thank you guys
so much for helping us promote this show
uh this week we are number 11 podcast in
the entire world
[Applause]
sometimes when someone says they're a
number or something podcast or a number
something best-selling book they're like
okay I'm the number one best-selling
book on Amazon among people who own
French Bulldogs or whatever I mean these
little nuanced categories but this is
the entire freaking Universe of three
million plus podcasts we're number 11.
so thank you guys very very much
our guys are for some reason they are
desperate to be in the top ten you can
help us if you share the podcast uh if
you share a link on it if you let people
know that we're out here uh if you leave
a review a five-star review if you want
to leave one star mama said if you ain't
got nothing nice to say don't say
anything at all don't bother just keep
your butt moving on to something else if
you don't like it it's okay and it's
what we do and probably not going to
stop doing it this way so anyway move on
and thank you for that and uh so
I don't want to so share subscribe leave
a review that's it yeah do all those
things click the follow button and all
that stuff right that's another thing
yep on Spotify it's now follow or not
apple as well uh yeah okay so follow
follow thank George Georgia knows the
technology I keep up yeah that's good so
yeah I just have people that tell me
what to do around here that know these
things so all right let's go uh move
back to the studio audience Jessica is
here hi Jessica how are you great how
are you better than I deserve where do
you live Fort Worth Texas ah love Fort
Worth welcome to Nashville how can we
help my husband and I are debt free
except for our mortgage yay thank you
thanks to you guys
so here's my question I've been waiting
to see what is going to happen to our
credit score now that we have no other
debt except our mortgage I'm not sure if
it's going to eventually become
unreportable or if it's just going to
dwindle down and make it harder for us
to buy another house which we might be
doing in the next year or so so what
will happen to our credit score
well we're not sure to be honest with
you because uh the folks at FICO hold
for good reason and they should hold the
details of their algorithm very tightly
because if they didn't then people would
spend their entire lives trying to
manipulate their score so they should
not put out how this works but what we
think we see number one Assad aside from
that we do know that if you have zero
activity and zero accounts open of any
kind the only thing we're reported are
closed paid off accounts that in
somewhere around six months as you said
your score will be undeterminable but
you have an account that's open it's
called a mortgage so you're sitting
there paying the payment paying the
payment paying the payment wait a minute
I got a test case right here you had a
mortgage and then you paid it off before
you paid it and you had no score when
you got the mortgage correct so you I
would assume you got a score after that
so what you're sitting there with one
account a mortgage paying it what
happened to the score it disappears
after six or seven months no after you
paid the house off
round while you were paying the house
though and you had a score it created a
score and it was a good score go down no
after it came in no what was your score
do you know I think it was in the 700s
so with just a single house payment
paying it on time no other accounts at
all you had a 700 yes then you'll be
fine
so it's not going to ding you now here's
the thing if you're going to buy a house
within six months after you pay it off
you think or would it be a while
we're probably about a year out from
buying a house and we've been debt free
except the mortgage for a little over a
year but you're not gonna pay off the
house before you probably won't buy yeah
we probably won't pay it off okay so
you're going to be sitting there just
paying a payment like he did with a
single one account open that has
activity on it and you pay it on time
you're probably going to be in the 700
that I'm you I've got a one person case
study that I base that on okay very
scientific um but anecdotally that's
what I've seen conceptually that's what
we've heard is that it it doesn't it
doesn't just like keep going down into
the 600s the low 600s even down into
500s right just because you only have
one account if you only have one account
you pay it properly on time it should
level off now you're not going to get an
880 with that because an 8 A.D is people
borrowing paying borrowing paying
they're they're trying to drive the
score and we do know that there's five
things FICO publishes this there are
five things that cause your score all of
them are related to being in debt and
how you relate to debt and how you pay
the debt and none of them are related to
your income your Financial Health your
net worth we do know that FICO publishes
that so the FICO score is not a measure
for those of you that don't know of
Financial Health it's a measure of how
much you've been playing kissy face with
the bank that's all it is and so uh you
know to worship at the altar of the FICO
scores to worship at the altar of Bank
of America which is a really stupid butt
idea but in your case you've got a very
valid thing that you're trying to uh
manage your life in such a way while
being responsible that doesn't keep you
from getting this next house but it
sounds like you're probably going to be
I mean generally speaking that you you
probably if you had up close to 800 you
paid off a bunch of stuff and it's come
down into the 700s or you know and it's
and it should have leveled off and it
should just sit there that's what we've
been seeing in general and I'm glad I
could confirm that with you I just
realized I had one sitting here yeah
yeah and there's three things that would
happen number one you guys upgrade with
cash which would be a cool goal for your
next house number two you get a mortgage
and you still have a credit score and
the mortgage company uses that and it'll
probably be a good score or number three
the credit score goes away and you go
through the manual underwriting process
and so either way you're going to be
good to go there you're doing it the
right way well the credit score will not
go away as long as you have that
mortgage on the books yeah good question
thank you for stopping by I appreciate
you being here today
[Applause]
let's go to Nick in Milwaukee on the
phones hi Nick welcome to the Ramsey
Show good afternoon sir afternoon
okay my question is I was told that we
should get a home excuse me home equity
line of credit to add to our retirement
profile
who who told you that what is your
thought I was told by our Banker that
that makes sense that makes sense your
Banker told you you should be in debt
I'm so shuffled
wow well we're not bankers and so we
have your best interests at heart they
just want your interest and so here's
what I would tell you
uh the HELOC puts your home in Jeopardy
and puts you further into debt and so I
don't understand how this is a smart
part of like a wealth building plan the
smartest thing to do would be to pay
your house off not use a HELOC pay cash
for everything and not have your home at
risk because your home is collateral
with that HELOC
correct that's a safer retirement in my
book Nick let me let me um just be real
very very clear okay if you want to
build wealth the best thing you can do
with a banker is never talk to them
again okay
okay
I have never met a millionaire that says
I used all my Bankers advice and so I
became a millionaire never once has that
ever happened it's never come up they're
they're they're they're really really
bad at everything except getting you
into debt they re you know if you've got
a financial planner that works at your
bank don't use them get another one
because he need he couldn't get a good
job I mean he got stuck at the bank I
mean it sucks so you know that's the
thing you want to do for sure that's
just um oh my goodness gracious yeah and
the second thing then Nick is to uh
always be sitting with someone with a
heart of a teacher and uh when you have
a conversation that sounds like the one
he had uh when you get home you need to
take a shower because you know you've
been in the president slime
and so it's you know but and we don't we
all know that feeling right and slimy
people and so you need someone with the
heart of a teacher not the heart of a
Salesman that guy had nothing to do with
Nick's best interests they sell that
that is what they do matter of fact I
don't even want my savings account where
that guy is he's either uh he's either
after your with malice or he's just
dumber than a rock and both are really
dangerous this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
here with 1500 of our closest friends at
the Ramsey live event center
Ken Coleman George Campbell Ramsey
personalities are my co-hosts today a
lot of questions particularly this time
of year about taxes let's unpack one
from one of our listeners what happens
if you file your taxes late uh you'll be
penalized and if you pay them late
you'll be penalized with interest and
you definitely want to avoid that
especially if you owe taxes here's why
if you missed the tax filing deadline
you'll be charged a late filing penalty
uh a failure to file penalty a uh just
we don't like you penalty they come up
with all kinds of penalties up there
it's pretty cool and the longer you wait
the worse the penalty is and the more
the interest is the longer you wait to
pay there is no penalty if you miss the
deadline and don't owe taxes but if the
IRS owes you a refund of course you
won't get your money back until you file
here's an interesting thing too that
we've learned over the years people in
crisis uh with their taxes are in crisis
with their finances and their taxes uh
they do not put people in jail for
failure to pay
they will put people in jail 2579 last
year for failure to file
it is against the law to not file your
taxes but we do not have a debtor's
prison yet
um
and so not paying your taxes is uh
obviously not a good idea but uh you
know the big thing is make sure you file
and the best thing you can do even if
you can't pay is file on time yeah all
right because it gets rid of some of the
other penalties just on failure to file
so for God's sakes file your taxes and
uh I'm off the grid no you're not
you're just my favorite is the crypto
Bros who are like it's unregulated like
what's the first question when you fire
taxes did you make money from crypto
so much for your unregulated money guys
from America if you were if you're a U.S
citizen is taxable it's period I mean
it's just that's unless it falls under a
deduction under the regulations but you
don't get to go oh well I don't have to
report that it's cash no that's not how
it works so uh all right okay open
phones to this hour at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're also taking live questions today
from our live studio audience from the
floor up next is going to be Matt hi
Matt hey how are you great man where do
you live doing good Green Bay Wisconsin
very cool good to have you sir how can
we help uh so just wondering if uh one
of my parents passed away if they have
debt where does that go
well when someone passes away what you
own
has to stand good for what you owe
and so if they have any assets like say
they had a house or say they had a car
or something like that those items have
to be sold to pay their debts before
there's an inheritance if there's money
in a bank account it had to be used to
pay their debts before there is an
inheritance if someone dies uh with a
negative net worth where they owe more
than they own then some of those debts
are simply not going to be paid they
don't you children do not inherit debt
in America okay our current legal system
you do not inherit debt but it does keep
you from you can't go I'm going to keep
Grandpa's truck but we're not going to
pay any of his bills no that's not how
it works okay Grandpa's truck is one of
his assets and so you can't just go I
get to keep the assets and not pay the
debts but uh but but you know you don't
have to worry about inheriting a bunch
of debt from someone who's got a
horrible financial situation all dead
and no money or whatever but you can't
keep things the biggest place that comes
into play that's really painful is if
one of the spouses they've kept their
money separate which is stupid and uh
one of the spouses has run up a bunch of
debt and they own a house together
and so Papa dies and Papa has 80 000 in
credit card debt because Grandma
couldn't tell him nothing right and so
but they own a house together well she's
got to pay that eighty thousand dollars
in credit card debt in order to keep the
house because half of that house is his
and it has to stand good for his stuff
and so you can't that's the problem of
being in Partnerships with people too as
you get in this exact same mess so
um but as far as you like for your
parents as an example I don't know if
you're talking about a for real example
but if your parents died and had a bunch
of debt it does not wash over to you but
you can't have any of their assets until
that debt is paid and if you co-sign for
it you would be liable but as long as
you're not a co-signer or any of their
debt you're good the creditors may try
to come after you they don't have any
legal standing you send a death
certificate and it goes away people get
confused like uh I I I want grandpa's
house but do I have to pay his mortgage
yeah
yeah because they'll foreclose on the
house you're not technically liable for
the mortgage but they have a lien
against that house and so they'll take
the freaking house if you don't pay it
the weird thing is you can actually take
over the mortgage and you're still not
technically financially responsible for
the mortgage but in someone's death but
uh but the house still stands good for
the mortgage and so you if you want to
keep the house you got to pay the
mortgage and so or pay it off or
whatever you're going to do so those
things stand that way but what when you
die your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe if there's anything left
only then is there an inheritance if
there's a negative figure left then
somebody's not going to get paid and
we've had to walk sadly in financial
coaching sessions through with people
where we go okay
dad died and he left sixty thousand
bucks worth of credit card debt and
they're calling me wanting the money and
I'm like well you don't know the money
so all you got to do is get your dad's
death certificate send them a copy of it
and go he go Bank of America here's what
you get nothing which is kind of fun
but yeah because it's what you deserve
you're only an 89 year old 600 642 000
on a credit card you deserve to burn
right and so you get nothing and just
show them the death certificate because
that's what they get nothing because
there's nothing there dad's got nothing
he died in an apartment nothing his
clothes are all that's there that's it
penniless and and we've had to walk
people through get the death certificate
to get them off your back because you
don't know it you simply don't that does
not transfer generationally and so
open phones here thank you sir very good
call very good question appreciate you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
[Applause]
Ken and George talk a little bit about
uh this thing we're getting more and
more and more of it uh we had a weird
call I guess it was yesterday or day
before uh of a will that had gone bad
um an estate planning thing that had
gone about how important it is to get
your estate plan in place and inform
everyone the details of it while you're
alive well number one everyone in this
room you guys don't have to worry about
dying with debt because y'all are going
to be debt free with money to burn and
leave to your children's children that's
the goal
that is my goal for everyone listening
everyone in this room and on the will
side people think Dave they're gonna
like somehow die earlier if they have a
will but the truth is a will just is how
you say I love you to your family the
last thing I want is grieving on top of
a financial mess because they don't know
where to find half the crap the
government then has to decide what
happens through probate that's a
nightmare it's not it's so much easier
in today's world now you can just do it
online we've got Mama Bear legal forms
it took me 20 minutes and I was done
yeah
yeah I think I think I would add is just
looking at it as a father of three
um and and by the way this plays into
life insurance as well and so I hope you
listen to our message about taking care
of your family and I sleep better at
night number one but number two is my
parents are getting older they're now in
their mid 70s and and talking with them
and making sure that they've got
everything set it takes the tension out
of a season of grieving and I think
that's what I've always appreciated
about what Dave teaches about that is
that it's very clear the directives
about what I want to happen with my
assets and everything are very very
clear it takes the argument out of the
situation and allows people to grieve
and then move on and it's part of
leaving a legacy we teach that all the
time absolutely you want to change your
family tree and leave a legacy have a
will so that we're not happy that you're
gone but we are not grieving over the
nightmare we have to take over with your
finances and the assets yeah I mean the
world's worst is a bunch of hillbillies
in the backyard where the metal detector
trying to find the coffee can I got that
call Dave he had a hundred grand in
coffee cans I said what's your address
I'll be right there yeah by the way it
still happens today uh since we're
making big announcements this is not as
momentous as what you're saying to
people earlier but uh I've decided to
change my will and uh at the time of my
untimely death you will get all of my
shoes I
oh that's such a blessing wait what size
are you
I I don't know if does that matter size
kind of it killed the joke George sorry
I was hoping you were going to say golf
clubs honestly oh no you got some nice
clothes my shoes are worth way more than
my golf clubs
that's one of those like you know you
might be a redneck you know you might be
Metro if your shoes are worth more than
your Golf Club
S I had to get him back he made the Gap
Kids joke I had to get him back before
the show was over there we go see you
walk into it that's right yeah mess with
the bear I love it kid Coleman George
Campbell this hour good show gentlemen
this is the Ramsey Show Sports camel if
you like what you're heard in the show
and want to know more
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
Make some noise for Ken Coleman George
Campbell
those Goons
[Applause]
you guys still having fun you still
doing good out there
oh going strong that's what I like to
hear all right some of you have already
discovered this is a break so we have
about five minutes in this break if you
guys need to pop out and go grab another
cookie just keep them going actually
they're free just get as many as you can
in your system it's good for you I read
that somewhere online but while we do
that I want to introduce you guys to
something that we're really excited
about we have a lot of things we're
excited about that's going on because
there's a lot of changes including a
brand new host who are entree leadership
podcast who listens to podcasts in the
room Mr hands who's podcast listeners
oh yeah I don't know if you guys know
this but our newly minted host of the
entree leadership podcast is none other
than Dave Ramsey
he's been bringing the Heat and so I
decided to bring out the show producer
this is Tim Hall everyone say hi to him
hi guys
he's super pumped to be out here it's
really fun to stand in front of like a
thousand strangers so I really
appreciate that you're out here to share
with us a little bit about the show now
now that Dave's on there I'm sure it's
just a lot more tame quiet you know
probably really even Keel uh what can
people expect when they tune into the
show well they can expect you know
business and Leadership questions
getting answered by Dave Ramsey from his
30 plus years of experience you know
stuff like family business issues Pro
people problems uh everything you know
all the way to hiring and you know
let's see what else we got you know
there's all kinds of stuff we're hitting
yeah yeah you know Dave's bringing his
experience to the table and really you
know breathing life into people as well
as telling them when they messed up yeah
so now that we're doing a caller-based
show so people are calling in small
business owners from all over the nation
or calling in with their questions and
he's able to answer those live on the
air that's right that's awesome that's
so so cool I love it you guys make sure
you tune in and check it out and just to
give you a little bit of an idea of what
you might discover and find when you
tune in we got to show you this clip
here check this out
so if you're looking for Theory from a
business professor who has never made
payroll you've got the wrong show
you got questions about business
particularly small business Kayla is in
Evansville Indiana I'm Colleen because
my business is growing and I'm thinking
about adding employees you want somebody
to just talk it through with you Grady's
with us in Vermont how do we save for
future Capital purchases without paying
drunk uncle Steve which is what I call
the IRS or congress any extra tax I love
you enough to tell you the truth even if
it sounds a little bit like I'm mad at
you Griffin is in Seattle Washington uh
bottom line I guess my question is what
do I do he's got to go man there are
days that leadership just straight up
sucks yeah because I want you to win
we're not in this to lose a business
that does not make a profit is called a
hobby so let's fix this let's get her
going boys and girls
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
actual amazing relationships
we're hanging out today doing the show
live with 1500 of our closest friends a
live studio audience possibly the
largest live studio audience we've ever
had on the show the phone number if you
want to participate from afar is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll be taking calls from across
America we'll also be taking questions
from here in the auditorium Rachel Cruz
number one best-selling author co-host
of the ever popular smart money happy
hour and my daughter is with me this
hour thank you thank you
so fun to be here you should do this all
the time we should there's a lot of
energy doing this oh great y'all are
awesome sure the show is more fun when
we're not in a glass Booth by ourselves
that's it and uh Dr John deloney number
one best-selling author Ramsay
personality also my co-host this hour
[Applause]
again the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Evan is going
to start us off from the floor this hour
hi Evan how are you hi uh how are you
better than I deserve where do you live
uh from Kansas City cool welcome to
Nashville thank you how can how can we
help today
um it's a huge honor to be here today
um so I grew up in a Ramsay household
um I uh save I've been saving for
retirement since I was uh 18 and I have
no debt
um so I just finished my first year of
my uh career job
and I'm wanting to buy a house and I'm
not really sure how to do that when my
income is currently as low as it is
because you know I've just kind of
started
um so basically I'm just wanting to know
like what's the best way to save for a
house well I'm starting a career because
you know it's not like
um what do you do so I'm a production
artist uh so I uh modify artwork to be
printed on glass and apparel
um so what do you like uh 19 an hour
okay all right cool very good good for
you
yeah so I would say Evan if I were in
your shoes I would just be okay renting
I mean you're just starting out so I'm
assuming I mean how old are you I'm 25
25 that's great so yeah I mean at this
point when we look at large purchases
specifically even a home I mean math
plays a huge role in that right and so
so what can you do to create less stress
and more margin in your life well going
and buying a home right now that's out
of your budget and out of your reach
will cause less margin and probably a
lot of stress and so I think it's fine
to slow step your way as your income
starts to build to put more and more
away and it's okay to rent for a few
years I just feel like people renting is
such a Negative
feeling around I feel like our culture
right I mean I just feel like people are
like oh you're renting you're just
throwing money away oh my gosh you're
just terrible you're a sinner you're
like the worst
and and renting is okay for a bit and so
honestly I would be okay with it have
patience and have that have a goal that
you look out and say hey and four but in
four years I want to have this much
money say they want to be making this
much in in a job and so have things that
you're reaching for but right at this
moment I would be okay just being
patient
good plan yeah you said it I'm just
getting started I make 19 an hour can't
afford a house right now
and that that's the reality that you're
in so what you do need to do since
homeownership and wealth building are
part of your uh one of your goals or
some of the things you're asking about
then you need to start seeing away with
your career how you are going to
increase your income and then that get
because that's when you're going to be
able to do some of those other things so
you don't want to have a projection say
okay when I'm 45 I'm making 19.50 an
hour that's not a plan okay so we got to
have how are we going to double this how
are we going to Triple this how are we
going to start our own business in this
area what what types what other ways can
I use this skill that pays a whole lot
more whatever it is and it's not not to
say be dissatisfied where you are today
but I'm saying for your future we've got
to say uh my friend Henry Cloud says
when you identify your desired future
yours is build some wealth and own a
house
okay what has to be true Henry says
that's not true now
and in your case we've described you
we've got to get your income up and that
may be the maturation of your career
track as you mature and walk through
your career that may be the natural way
your income comes up it may be that you
go I'm going to use these same skills
and go over here and make three times
more but for now you're fine and just
rent as patience today but
um you know the the culture we lit or
the the price ranges of homes and the
interest rate environment we're in 19 an
hour is not a house buyer usually uh as
a single income household and Evan the
other encouraging thing is too that for
you you said I've been saving for
retirement since I was 18 and I was like
that's awesome so honestly when you get
a little bit more traction under your
feet career-wise and you see your income
come up you can pause investing save up
a down payment because you're not you're
going to be okay do you know what I mean
so even when that time comes to throw
even more money to save up for a down
payment pause your investing when that
time comes hey Evan can I use EU since
you're standing here in front of I don't
know 1500 of your clothes as friends can
I use you as a as a as a global issue in
our culture is that cool so all right
what's he gonna say thanks John no thank
you well I mean it depends on what issue
we're going to cover John
I I remember being terrible at math as a
kid and I loved it when we had to do
standardized testing and math because
they put the answer like in I knew it
had to be one of A B C or D and I always
hated it when it said e like none of the
above because then it took away like I
couldn't just reverse engineer the
answers all the way we live in a culture
that says I want a house
I deserve a house I should get a house I
want a car I want a great marriage I
want kids that are respectful and that
love me
but then we look back at the variables
that are making up that equation it's
like I don't make this this much money
and I but I want to have be in this
community I want to live in New York and
I want to make 14 an hour but I want to
buy a nice house I want a great marriage
I just don't want to talk to my husband
and I want my wife to read my mind I
want to have great kids I just don't
want to tell them no and just give them
screens all the time and then they're
going to be respect like we have to
address the variables on the front end
of this thing and not the back end
we don't make enough money we got to
start talking to our kids we gotta get
more engaged with our spouses whatever
that looks like in the back end the
answer to this math problem will always
solve itself if we take care of the
variables up front we stop trying to
focus on the answer and get on the get
on the front end of that good question
sir thank you for joining us
[Applause]
teachers if you want to know how
important your job is just ask anyone
who their favorite teacher was I can
name about a bunch of them and they were
all my favorites uh had the biggest
impact on you without a doubt we have
the Ramsey teacher appreciation giveaway
this month sponsored by the Army
National Guard it's in celebration of
April being financial literacy month so
anyone that is a teacher if you're an
in-classroom teacher one teacher is
going to win a five thousand dollar
vacation to wherever they want to go and
two more teachers are going to win a
three thousand dollar vacation of their
choosing and so you're going to pick
pick out where it is we're going to
write them a check for that and it's
again sponsored by the fine folks at the
Army National Guard all of us like
saying thank you to teachers if you know
a teacher or you are a teacher go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher and enter no
purchase is necessary don't we all love
teachers
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're a teacher out there thank you
thank you thank you for what you do and
who you are we really really appreciate
you
Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personalities my co-host this hour here
on the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
very cool well what was that what's the
what's the secret oh we can't we can't
get into that right now because we're on
a very tight timetable yes because I
brought your show producer Lindsay
Heatherly you didn't need anything
[Applause]
it's like living in a world with two
sons they're so bright and full of life
and energy and goodness it's true it's
true I brought Lindsay out here to talk
a little bit about the Rachel Cruz show
which is awesome and fantastic if you
have not seen it yes we got some fans
out there
I'm going to show you guys a clip in
just a second but real quick Lindsay can
you tell people what you love besides
Rachel what you love about the Rachel
Cruz show yes I love that Rachel gives
practical and tactical money advice
around like getting out of debt
um saving Building Wealth
um and she's super fun she's like your
wise best friend that you need in your
life so I love that about the Rachel
Cruz show true that yes that's true uh
John wrote that about her so
um all right so without further Ado this
is a really tight break so I want you
guys to see this this is just a little
clip to give you a better picture of the
Rachel crew show check this out
hey guys welcome to this episode of the
Rachel Cruz show
so the Rachel Cruz show is mainly based
around your money but we all know that
your money is involved in all areas of
your life I know the challenges that I
have with money and I'm sure that that
means other people have those challenges
budgeting is the thing that has helped
me so so much so how can it help you so
my goal for the show and really for the
content is I want to hit people right
where they're at so the topics we cover
on the show are all over the map but
that's what's important because money
affects all areas of Our Lives
one of my favorites is actually talking
about what you could do this weekend to
start changing your financial future
it's so important because these little
money happens you guys are huge I also
love them we have guests on I started
realizing that that is lots of inventory
that I have to manage but it's also
extra money out of our budget that we
didn't really have it's decluttered so
it's everything from like a car expert
to a nutritionist minimalist living whoa
so I love being able to share my
platform with other people who are
experts in what they do if Rachel Cruz
says it's worth it it's worth it I'm
wrong started with me and a tripod and a
camera this is the introductory video of
my new video blog and now it's a team of
20 people and I love my team
but just even the heart and the soul
that they bring and the ideas and so
what people see the results of every
show it is such a team effort one thing
I really hope people take away from
every episode is just a glimmer of hope
that's what I want from people to know
that they can that they can change the
course of how they handle money and the
power is in them and remember to take
control of your money and create a life
you love I end every show with take
you love you may go through seasons of
sacrifice to get out of debt and to
build up your emergency fund but you
also may go through seasons of life
where you get a raise and you get to
enjoy your money and so taking control
of your money and creating a life you
love are two statements that I deeply
believe in
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
so Kate Middleton
[Music]
oh
way too much fun at the commercial
breaks this is the Ramsey show thank you
for joining us we're live from the
Ramsey Event Center with Dr John deloney
and Rachel Cruz Ramsay personalities
Welcome to our 1500 closest friends
thank you for hanging out with us today
guys
today's question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services here at Ramsey we believe in
making home ownership a blessing not a
burden so we recommend neighborly's
network of service professionals to
repair maintain improve your home find
the help you need at neighborly.com in
all seriousness people this is a great
company and they have a great group of
folks they work with all across America
check them out
neighborly.com today's question of the
day is actually coming from here inside
the Opera inside the auditorium dini is
with us hi deeney I'm excited to be here
well we're honored to have you where do
you live Miami Florida oh fun that's
where Miss Jade is from that area down
there Fort Lauderdale area yeah cool our
Fort Myers area I'm sorry how can we
help my question is about budget I have
a 13 year old daughter and a 14 year old
daughter and they hear me talk about
budget a lot a lot of times when I do
it's because I'm about to say no and
um you know they think budget this
budget that and I don't want it to be
negative I want it to be positive but I
think a lot about it being positive is
to give them the knowledge of what I'm
talking about kind of the intricacies
and so what age do I show them the
budget because when they see the budget
they see the income and do I want to
tell them how much money I make
how much money do you make
as they watch the show I'm like oh
um well combined we make 3 30 ish you
make a lot good I'm glad for you
you weren't jumping
okay so um
I would say our household growing up do
you need the secrets out so you can have
a seat I know sorry
so we grew up never knowing specific
numbers
but our numbers are ridiculous
and and we're in the spotlight with as
celebrities in the community and we
didn't want some teenager running around
you know with that information that
wouldn't have been healthy
we're in an unusual situation in that
regard sure but I would also say if you
make even the amount of money you I mean
you that's a lot of money so I'm like
she does so so I can see the more
cautions you know what I'm saying like
um uh we have some friends and then they
do well and they have teenagers and they
they show them everything and they
actually have done this uh routine a few
months in a row because the mom was just
so frustrated with like how just kind of
like casual they were without money and
she took their whole paycheck cashed it
out and she had utilities here cable I
mean she went through their cell phone
insurance for their car I mean she
divided everything up on the kitchen
table like three months in a row because
she was like I wanted them to visually
see what was going on and I thought how
powerful that was so depending on how
comfortable you feel sharing numbers
there is a part of me that kind of likes
it and does it kind of open up that and
just to say I need you to really
understand and see this and then on the
flip side when you said budget ends up
being kind of a negative when you guys
get do get to do great things I'm sure
you do with your income I'm like you
guys are probably able to take some
Great Vacations or whatever it is say
it's in the budget
yay we get to go shopping it's in the
budget you know like make it an exciting
thing so when you do say no no it's not
in the budget they still know that a
budget isn't doesn't mean no budget does
not equal no budget means it equals we
are in control which means also we can
spend on this side and enjoy but also we
have to have a boundary and a limit at
some point and say no so so introducing
both someone's something exciting
happens with them
and they go and buy something or you
guys take a great vacation just
celebrate the budget with that too we
did uh disclose when they were 12 13 14
15 the household operational budget it
did not disclose our entire income but
so that they could see okay this is what
the light bill costs this is what the
phone bill is this is what the uh you
know the whatever the taxes Insurance
whatever it is so they can see the basic
stuff because what we're trying to do
here is not control their current
behavior with this lesson we're trying
to show them how this is done properly
because our friend Andy Andrew says he
said we're not trying to raise great
kids we're trying to raise kids who
become great adults so we're trying to
give you adult skills and so when I'm
talking to a 14 or 15 year old I'm
speaking to the 30 year old version of
them I want them to say Okay the reason
I'm showing you this is so that when
you're 30 you're this you understand and
the reason I'm sure the reason we're
saying no is this and it's not we never
used the budget one time as a weapon
it's not the budget we can't do it
instead we were saying we've got these
goals this much money we're choosing to
do these other things with it and so it
means we're not doing this because
that's that that is how a budget works
is we're actually choosing that but what
we're teaching them there is a critical
thinking skill path that says okay
choices have to be made because you're
not in Congress you have a limit on your
money and so you have to make choices
and so in order to say yes you've got to
say no now so in extreme income
situations maybe you would use a uh an
operational budget like we did uh and
and if you've got smaller kids we don't
even get into that but I mean but with
smaller kids it's about principles well
principals and there is something to say
about a dollar amount our eight-year-old
because they're they're doing chores and
earning a dollar or two here and there
and we went out to dinner after
um church on Saturday night because we
did Easter on Saturday night anyways and
it was seventy dollars to go out to
dinner and Winston said that to me in
the car he's like yeah I was 70 bucks
and we're like okay and my
eight-year-old goes it was seventy
dollars
because their heart felt like 700 how
many chores would that take me to save
70 so I thought I'm so glad that she
heard that because it is a lot I mean
like life is expensive and so when they
can grasp almost these dollar amounts
there is a tactical lesson where they
kind of start to see and uncover and
Rachel looked at she just looked back
and said don't worry I'm re-wearing this
shirt so it's good
hey here's one thing I've done
differently with my daughter than my son
my son is 13 and my daughter's seven
um I over disclosed to my son and tried
to be super hip transparent dad with my
seven-year-old it's much more about
she's got the the toy that the the the
bank that they sell in the Ramsey store
that's the one she uses and she's got
save and give and spend and one thing I
was real bad about was in her spend
money I tried to also control that
and so I've
taking my hands a little bit off so she
wants to buy something dumb that I think
is dumb that's the money she's earned
and it's not going to be there if she
decides to spend it and I wanted to
learn this when she's seven not have me
curating what she's going to spend later
but she gets when I say this isn't in
the budget or we're not going to spend
this much money on this thing she
doesn't need to know the dollar amount
because she gets the principal right and
that's been super helpful and Danny this
doesn't come up in your situation but it
does come up uh if your family is in a
financial bad situation we don't talk to
seven-year-olds about foreclosures yeah
we don't know that that worker protects
badly or bad and so what's the phrase
you have scare but what is this share
but don't scare and so you can share and
say you know Mom and Dad are having a
hard time right now or you know we're
having to move but you don't have to go
you know because apparently you dump
your drama on your kid it becomes trauma
yes to your point it's really important
to be honest with your kids because your
kids are going to feel your attention
they're going to feel you weeping
they're going to feel all that and
they're going to think it's their fault
they're going to be seven and think I
I'm doing this to Mom and Dad let them
know things are really really tough
right now and Mom and Dad are scared
and this is what we're gonna do and they
get to see an adult be scared just like
all of us and then act like an adult on
the back end and not just scream kicking
so the moral story is in your situation
I I would open it up at least
operationally whether it's income or not
as long as you can put around it uh the
idea that we're not going to uh share
our family's income outside this home
okay we're although I'm just made you
but yeah but the uh
but the uh uh but I mean I didn't want
our kids trumping through the
neighborhood saying my dad makes this
versus what's your dad you know that
kind of crap right what do we do
you would
that was a really nice teenager you were
a really nice team but uh but then
somewhere think about what that phrase
means a really nice teenager yeah there
you go so hey thank you thank you this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
and I'm like don't say that
all right all right all right back by
popular demand I brought with me Lindsay
Heatherly uh
your favorite I know we won't tell the
others it's fine uh brought Lindsay out
here to talk about a show that we have
that is actually a newer one and I don't
know if you guys are aware of this but
it's called a smart money Happy Hour
podcast
questions
I love that they've heard I love it this
is great well have you guys also watched
it on YouTubes
how about that set design she crafted
that by hand I just want you guys to
know that she made it all possible
should you talk about a little bit about
we're going to show you a little clip
from it but first I would love for you
to explain to these fine folks that
maybe don't know and are about to be
invited into what smart money happy hour
is all about and then sure about this
clip we're gonna watch yeah so smart
money happy hour
um something I love about it is it takes
out the intimidation Factor about money
conversations with people
um so Rachel and George you know they're
money experts but they're also friends
so this show is them talking about what
you find yourself talking about with
your friends and family at home
um everything from pop culture current
events all surrounding the topic of
money so it's really fun and we have a
really good time uh they cover all kinds
of things like chat GPT and Mickey
Manilow right I think it's another one
on there love is blind I'm just blind
which is the popular subject of
conversation on these parts but to give
you guys a little bit of taste of that
we're gonna show you a clip from Smart
money happy hour check it out
okay but explain it because I don't even
know if I get it you just type in so
it's AI it only has information from
2021 and previous oh really I didn't
know that if you're trying to if you're
trying to Google something that's
current and trending it's terrible
because it has no idea um
but it is a genius tool to
frame up thoughts it can write copy it
can help you with your resume do it
right now pull up your phone I'm going
to do write a funny limerick about
Rachel Cruz involving budgets and her
husband Winston
and it's going to do it would you be
impressed if it could do that on the Fly
I mean it's very specific okay and
within seconds it gave me the Limerick
do it
there once was a gal named Rachel Cruz
her budgeting skills she didn't abuse
she and Winston so fine made their
finances align now they laugh all the
way to the bank they don't lose
that's pretty good that's unbelievable
yeah so if you need anything written for
you yeah you could be like uh give me
some motivation about getting out of
debt in the style of Dave Ramsey and it
would sound like do it all right are you
sure you want to hear this I do first do
you have any that you're like you have a
dark curiosity about that you're just
jonesing for no give me motivation
for getting out of debt
in the voice of and they can do it in
the voice of yeah
this is crazy
oh here we go okay give me motivation
for getting out of debt in the style of
Dave Ramsey here's what channel GPT is
coming up with in real time
debt can hold you back from reaching
your financial goals and enjoying true
Financial Peace by following Dave
Ramsey's seven baby steps you can get
out of debt and take control of your
money remember debt is a form of slavery
the more debt you have the harder it is
to be truly free by getting out of debt
you'll have more money to put towards
your future whether that's saving for
retirement buying a house or sending
your kids to college the journey may be
hard but the reward at the end is worth
it so let's roll up our sleeves make a
plan and get to work the finish line is
in sight and Financial Freedom is
waiting for you holy that's crazy you're
gonna take us out of a job I feel like
you're in the kitchen wow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author multiple times and my daughter is
my co-host this hour as we're
broadcasting live from the brand new
Ramsay Event Center with 1500 of our
closest friends
foreign
if you don't know we do this show every
day Monday through Friday from one to
four it's usually two of us at a time
we've done a little differently this
week because of uh or this day because
we're celebrating the opening of this
event center but you can join us anytime
outside our studios are on the glass
down in the Ramsey headquarters in the
lobby and there's always free cookies
and free coffee uh there and as you guys
have had when you came in today we had
cookies and coffee waiting on you when
you came in today and so you could enjoy
that same experience and we just we love
getting to meet the folks from All Over
America they stopped by on their way to
a vacation or their way to whatever
they're in Nashville for something else
and they come down here to Franklin just
south of Nashville and hang out with us
we appreciate all of you hanging out we
get to we love getting to see you and
talk to you and hear your stories and it
keeps us going it keeps us moving it
gives us the energy
and so everything we do at Ramsey is for
the people that are not at Ramsey
it's all for the people outside our
walls and you're it you're why we built
this building so as an example so thank
you thank you thank you all right Scott
is on the line our Scott is here on the
floor I'm sorry hey Scott how are you
doing fine thank you so much for having
us in here it's a beautiful beautiful
space thank you sir where do you live uh
Spokane Washington I love Spokane
awesome very cool how can we help today
well I've got a two-part question on uh
transition and patience uh my wife and I
are in baby step seven and we are
finding it a little uh challenging to
transition from uh intense to
intentional so just looking for a little
bit of sage advice from y'all uh you
know how we can downshift yeah
okay go ahead uh
I I think it's number one it's a normal
thing to face that because once you've
been Frugal you've been very dialed in
to let your foot off the gas and
actually enjoy the ride a little bit is
not a natural thing your body is wired
you've set yourself in motion you've got
this thing dialed in and now you're
saying oh we're gonna do something
different and so uh Dr John always says
on other things practice practice a new
Behavior practice a new feeling and uh
so some of the things that Sharon and I
did was we were very careful to make
sure that we budgeted money to spend
because we hadn't been spending anything
and so we said okay we're going to put
money in this category and we're going
to put money in this vacation fund and
then we're going to spend it on a
vacation and if there's a bunch of money
in that vacation fund we're going on
someplace nice
you know
and uh when you've been
you know head down on the grindstone
pushing to stop and do that is an
unnatural act
you have to force yourself to do it the
first time or two and then you get
better the second thing we did and I
still do this to it to make sure I'm not
overdoing it or under doing it is we
look at ratios and ratios meaning uh
when I was broke spending x on a car was
ridiculous
spending 10x that on a car now is not
because there's a percentage of my world
it doesn't matter so if you got a
million dollars and you spend ten
thousand dollars on a car it's nothing
but if you have five dollars and you
spend ten thousand dollars on a car it's
a lot
so that's a ratio and so uh and we often
look and go okay if we do this and it's
completely wrong or we forgot to put
insurance on it and we lit it on fire
is it going to change our life no then
that's a small ratio it's a small
percentage of our net worth a small
percentage of our income then we can
enjoy that and it gives me permission to
enjoy it knowing that I'm not being
irresponsible
if you grew up like me I didn't grow up
with very much my wife didn't grow up
with very much money was a it was a
topic of of of war in our homes and then
we got older and we ran up six figures
so we did the whole thing right
Dave said practice this is I'm just
going to give you a straight vulnerable
cheesy answer from our very house
I travel a lot and I made the decision
for me I'm going to start parking right
up next to the airport and it's a
billion dollars and every time I did it
I remember not having that money in my
checking account for years and it was a
matter of ratios you can afford this
John it's okay and the first time me and
my wife were traveling I pulled in and
she said what are you doing and I said
this is where I park when I come to the
airport and she said this is ridiculous
once and then she was like oh this is
awesome right and so it but literally as
Dave said it's 35 a night to park there
something like that for me that my body
still feels like I'm 12 and 35 was our
light bill and we don't have it right so
I have to say this this sentence to
myself
I wasn't okay then I'm okay now I wasn't
okay then I'm okay now and then I've
gotta I've got to go do the thing and
it's something little like that but that
man that's that's that's that's been a
game changer for us you know what's
interesting Scott I feel like we talked
to a lot of people that are just like
you they have this question and they say
oh my even when they get into baby steps
four five and six like we've just been
so intense and I do Wonder I'd be
curious what you guys think about this
too there is something to be said when
you go through the baby steps there is
those seasons of sacrifice
and when you're so used to you know when
before the baby steps you accumulated
accumulating for some people you know
going to debt for stuff and then it's
like oh my gosh we got to get out of
debt so now we're gonna sell stuff we're
gonna work extra We're not gonna buy
stuff and you start to live life with
quote unquote less stuff I do think that
there is a level of contentment that
starts to play into your soul where you
realize wow we really don't need all
that crap that we had yes and you get to
this point and you're like
some stuff I just don't care to have
like like yeah maybe I can afford a nice
car but I just don't really care to have
it like I'm good with my you know 12
year old truck and that's good too so
there's a contentment piece so I would
ask the question why do I not want to
spend is it completely out of fear
because that plays I think it's y'all
but I also think that there's something
to be said of like
we just we just don't want to you know
buy a bunch of crap we don't need and
that's okay too that's an okay answer so
I do want to give you permission as long
as your motivation is we're kind of just
content where we're at we don't feel
like we need more that's okay too and
the last thing I would tell folks when
you get to this point too is
to um out of that contentment and out of
uh the new season that you're in you're
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
is um
Sharon and I have experienced that it
has given us permission to enjoy the
money
if a were responsible with ratios it's a
small amount of our life it's not a big
thing it may be a big thing to somebody
else but as a percentage you know it's a
small amount and B uh We've increased
our generosity
something about increasing the building
your generosity muscle bigger more and
more giving and more and more different
kinds of giving random stuff just buy
everybody's gas at the gas pumps that
you're standing there for a minute or
you know finding some single mom putting
tires on her car whatever I mean all
kinds of random stuff plus systematic
large giving as well but you just work
that giving muscle then all of a sudden
there's something that I don't know how
that's connected in our brains but it
gives us permission to be okay enjoying
some stuff
too and and so it plays out that way and
that that's how I would get at it so
really good question sir I appreciate
you bringing that up thank you for being
here God bless you
there is a thing of
if you're I've said this on Megyn Kelly
show the other day I said yeah Megan
it's like if you're going 100 miles an
hour down the interstate and then you
slow down to 55.
it feels weird she goes well I've never
had that feeling
so what you ought to drive faster man
it feels like you're walking right yeah
I mean it's it's it's a weird it's a
your everything slows down and changes
and that's that contentment thing too
you know one of the things I experienced
on that Rachel that was uh personally
was uh I I love cars I always have and I
was buying cars in my when I was a young
arrogant kid for other people to look at
and when I went broke I no longer care
what you think so now I buy cars because
I want them
if I buy a car now it's because it's a
car I wanted I don't know and it's the
motivation I don't really care whether
you like it or not you know it doesn't
matter to me because some of them are
great I want I want to drop that I like
that car you know that kind of thing it
changes but that changes the whole
equation then when you practice through
that yeah this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Matthew 5 14
and 16 you are the light of the world a
city set on a hill cannot be hidden nor
does anyone light a lamp and put it
under a basket but on a lamp stand and
it gives light to all those who are in
the house let your light shine before
men in such a way that they may see your
good works and glorify your father who
is in heaven
Desmond Tutu said hope is being able to
see that there is light despite all of
the darkness this is the Ramsey Show Dr
John deloney and Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personalities are my co-host this hour
it's been a very special day as we have
for this particular three hours been
broadcasting for the very first time
with our very first live event in the
Ramsey Event Center which is uh it is
owned by a a Ramsey trust a family trust
that is entitled Matthew 5 a city set on
a hill and uh this is on a hill for
those of you here uh if you walk out
front and you at night you see this
thing there's plenty of Lights uh
there's all kinds of this chandelier you
can see for six miles away uh this is a
city set on a hill this is put up here
for the purpose of Hope and uh so you
guys being here today is the culmination
of that uh 10-year Vision that 10-year
dream for that to happen and we're
honored to have had you guys today thank
you so much for being here
[Applause]
thank you
in our studio audience here Mark is with
us hey Mark how are you fantastic Dave
and congratulations on the Event Center
this is fantastic thank you so much
we're so honored to be here where do you
live sir uh Fate Texas ah uh Dallas area
yes sir all right cool good good to have
you sir John's a good Texas guy as well
so thank you how can we help today so my
question is
um in your 20s Dave you became a
millionaire and then you eventually lost
it and rebuilt rebuilt your wealth
take me and the audience back to the
time that you had a conversation with
Sharon and you decided
your path forward was to share your plan
with the millions of lives that you've
changed
and why you do what you do today
wow thank you wow that's neat well
Rachel and John are certainly involved
in that and they can chime in uh uh but
the history lesson is you're right it uh
26 years old and some change I had Banks
start calling notes on us we were doing
nothing down real estate before there
was Chip and Joanna to tell you how and
we deeply in debt lost everything over
the next two and a half years so when I
was 28 in September of that year
I turned 28 September 3rd and shortly
thereafter we filed bankruptcy filed
chapter seven Rachel was a brand new
baby she was born in April we filed in
September and Denise was a toddler and
so with a toddler and a brand new baby
in a marriage Hanging On by a thread
we've often said we got the opportunity
to start over the thing that the overlay
on that was uh when we first started
making money in real estate before all
that happened
uh was when I met God when we started
going to church and I met the Lord and
so I was studying scripture because I
didn't know anything it was dumber than
a rock and um uh so I was studying like
crazy about any part of life marriage
kids money anything just trying to learn
how to live and learn what the truth the
word of God says as a baby Christian a
brand new and I again I didn't know
beans some of y'all grew up you know
going to whatever going to Sunday school
when you were two or whatever I didn't
know any of that stuff so uh
and then uh so I'm starting all of that
and then I go broke in the middle of
that so you know we've got on the wall
down there if you visit the uh the uh
headquarters down there I met God on the
way up I got to know him on the way down
and and so walking through that process
and then learning God's ways of handling
money I didn't set out to do that uh for
other people I stood out to do that
because I was sick and tired of being
broke and uh and apparently the
information I had from uh uh my broke
Finance Professor that told me to go
deeply in debt was wrong so I needed
some new guidance and so I shifted and
then she we started Living sure and I
started Living on those uh biblical
principles and very very very gradually
we started to turn and we started to
have some hope again we started to
recover from the trauma and uh recover
from the destroyed self-esteem destroyed
reputation destroyed relationship and
relationships and and start to just
start to put our lives back together a
little bit at a time after this
hurricane had hit us and um that we that
I signed up for and uh and so then this
weirdest thing happened oyster a pastor
call one day and said uh hey there's a
couple in my office and foreclosure can
you show them how to not how to not get
foreclosed on yeah I used to buy
foreclosures and then I was one I know
exactly what to do so I went over met
with them and pastors usually don't know
a lot about technical stuff like that if
they know something about money they
don't know anything about technical
legal stuff so I got in there fixed
their foreclosure got them in a uh uh uh
you know got them in a plan with their
mortgage company and saved their house
and of course the problem with doing
something like that is you do it right
you get to do it again and so he started
calling me pretty regular so I ended up
helping a whole bunch of people and I
started figuring out these principles
apply to other people not just me but I
didn't set out to do that and we were
still I was back doing real estate deals
to eat and I think the last year I did
Real Estate I made 120 000.
and we figured out if we quit doing real
estate completely I just got on the
radio and they weren't paying me they
would let me do it for free which is
about what I was worth and
um uh we were starting Financial Peace
University and I was doing some speaking
and I had the little blue financial
piece book and we figured out the first
year we could probably make sixty
thousand if I quit doing real estate and
only did Financial Peace and we made 61
000 the next year
and so we took a pay cut in half and uh
but we started realizing okay God's
going to take our story
and use it to help other people
God's going to take the knowledge that
we gain from all that pain and use it to
help other people and it it went into a
career and then into calling and then
into a mission and uh if I wasn't doing
if I took a pay cut from 120 to 60 to do
it I sure wasn't doing it for money
and I'm still not doing it for money so
I don't know you guys have been on this
walk with us in the last uh obviously
you have your whole life and then you
know in this last little while comments
on that
yeah well from just his perspective you
know we always laugh because we're like
Dave is probably dad he's probably never
really going to retire from what we're
doing so we always kind of joke like
he's gonna be 92 and he's gonna be doing
the radio show and we're gonna be like
yeah great job Dave that was a great
show today and he's gonna go home
because we're like he's gonna he's gonna
think that he's doing it forever ever
amen there's gonna be a small little
closet over there in the just Baker
Street just plays on Loop and he's gonna
be like all right I'm doing it four
people listening how dedicated he is
though like I mean really like he he
really that is that is so true so so
true so but I know for our positions you
know it's uh as Ramsay personality is
it's a different
kind of a different door we entered in
to this message all of us in different
places and our stories uh but yeah being
able to to walk in this message and walk
out truly how it's affected each
individual us individually and then
what's so cool too now is that you know
as delony's talking about mental health
stuff Ken's talking about career it's
these other parts and these other
messages being able to give hope and so
as we stand on stages or sit in front of
microphones that we're able to tell our
stories and how this message is really
helped us and for me it's I'm that
second generation I am you know for so
many people their work in the plan and
they have little kids at home and I'm
like yeah I was that little kid you know
I will be your kids in the next 20 30
years and so uh being able to be that
voice of Hope For People Too has been a
fun
um perspective that I've been able to
hopefully bring I've never said this
publicly I'm gonna I'll I'll tell the
story now this is a personal like in
like just for me story but um it's
important I think in this I'm in art in
our history
um I I had resolved to not be on the
internet I didn't want to exist on the
internet I just wanted to show up behind
closed doors and help people and go home
and I like being on stage and all that
but I I didn't want any of this stuff
and I was finishing my counseling
program and I remember telling
um a woman who was one of my professors
a brilliant woman named Aretha marbley
Dr marbley and I she says what are you
doing because I was the dean of student
at the law school I was getting a degree
and I said I'm out I want to go be a
counselor in a small community and just
disappear and she looked at me and put
her finger up close and she said you
don't get to do that
you've got to make this world better and
they'll listen to you you don't get to
hide go show people another way and I
just put that in my back pocket and then
one day this guy called and then
everything's been different thank you
guys so much for being here
that puts this hour in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
jesusolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started